Humburglar, why are you calling? Rubble, rubble. McDonald's has a new biggest burger called Big Arch, made with two 100% Canadian beef patties, a new delicious sauce, and all the McDonald's flavors you love, and... Wait, you want me to help you get it? Rubble.
汉堡神偷，你为什么要打电话？Rubble, rubble。麦当劳推出了一款全新的超大汉堡，名叫Big Arch，它由两块100%加拿大牛肉饼、一种全新的美味酱汁以及你所钟爱的所有麦当劳风味制成，而且……等等，你想让我帮你买到它？Rubble。
Come on. Compared to beef burgers on McDonald's Current Menu at participating restaurants in Canada. Breaking news happens anywhere, anytime. Police have warned the protesters repeatedly, get back. CBC News brings the story to you as it happens. Hundreds of wildfires are burning. Be the first to know what's going on and what that means for you and for Canadians. This situation has changed very quickly. Helping make sense of the world when it matters most.
来吧。与加拿大参与活动的餐厅中麦当劳现有菜单上的牛肉汉堡相比。突发新闻随时随地都在发生。警方已多次警告抗议者，退后。CBC新闻为您实时报道。数百场野火正在燃烧。第一时间了解正在发生的事情，以及这对您和加拿大人意味着什么。这种情况变化非常快。在最重要的时候，帮助人们理解这个世界。
Stay in the know. CBC News. Welcome to Second Drink Health Care. I love this episode. It's one of my absolute favorites. Jenna, you know I have a t-shirt that I wear all the time. I've had it for years.
保持知情。CBC新闻。欢迎来到《Second Drink Health Care》。我喜欢这一集。这是我最喜欢的剧集之一。珍娜，你知道我有一件经常穿的T恤吗？我已经穿了好几年了。
It just says hot dog fingers. I know. Well, I love that we interview Rainn Wilson in this episode and he talks about the origin of hot dog fingers, which is such a great story. Yeah, let's dive in with some new tidbits. All right, well, I'll start because I promised
上面只写着“热狗手指”。我知道。嗯，我很高兴我们在这一集中采访了雷恩·威尔逊，他谈到了“热狗手指”的起源，这是一个非常棒的故事。是的，让我们深入了解一些新的花絮吧。好吧，我先来，因为我答应过
that I would track it and I'm delighted to report that at 45 seconds there is still a cat calendar at reception. Nice. I'm like, nice. I love that you're tracking this cat calendar. I'm on it. Well, one of the things I really love
我会追踪它，我很高兴地报告，在45秒处，接待处仍然有一个猫咪日历。不错。我就像，不错。我喜欢你追踪这个猫咪日历。我正在关注。嗯，我真的很喜欢的一件事
about these early episodes is getting to revisit the beginning of Jim and Pam. Yeah. Yeah. And if you want even more of that, there is a super duper cute Jim and Pam deleted scene for this episode. It's on the DVDs. Okay, so do you remember how Dwight made a sign
关于这些早期剧集，就是能够重温吉姆和帕姆的开始。是的。是的。如果你想要更多这方面的内容，这一集有一个超级可爱的吉姆和帕姆的删减片段。它在DVD里。好吧，你还记得德怀特是怎么制作一个标志的吗？
to hang on the conference room door while he was working on the healthcare plan? Yes, Dwight Schrute workspace. Very official. Well, I guess he made a few other signs before he settled on that one and he put them all in the trash and Pam and Jim take the trash can and they go sit together and they go through it and they read all the other ones. It is just cutesy, cutesy stuff.
在他制定医疗计划时挂在会议室门上？是的，德怀特·施鲁特工作区。非常正式。嗯，我想他在确定那个标志之前还做了其他几个标志，他把它们都扔进了垃圾桶，帕姆和吉姆拿走了垃圾桶，他们坐在一起，翻看它，读了所有其他的标志。这真是太可爱了。
I mean, it's just an excuse to flirt with one another, really. It's those early days when they just did anything so they could be together. Yes. I also loved watching it because you see our original location when you watch it. It's outside on this little tiny balcony overlooking the parking lot that does not exist
我的意思是，这真的只是他们互相调情的借口。那是他们早期为了能在一起而做任何事情的日子。是的。我也很喜欢看这一段，因为当你观看时，你会看到我们最初的拍摄地点。它在外面那个俯瞰停车场的微型小阳台上，那个阳台在
once we move to the sound stages. Yeah, and you see a whole different view, but I really want to play it for you guys. It's super cute. We stole Dwight's trash can and we found some of his early attempts at his sign. Okay, here's a, this is very simple. Dwight's workspace. Nice. This one's interesting.
我们搬到摄影棚后就不存在了。是的，你看到了一个完全不同的视角，但我真的很想给你们播放一下。它超级可爱。我们偷了德怀特的垃圾桶，发现了他在制作标志时的一些早期尝试。好吧，这是一个，非常简单。德怀特的工作区。不错。这个很有趣。
The power comes from the font in this one Shrewd space very medieval very England This one's forceful this one's very Dwight Quiet Dwight Shrewd working. It's good. I Really heard him on that this one's interesting. I'm not really sure what he meant by this Dwight Shute, privates. Tough to say. You are so stinking cute in this scene, Jenna.
这个字体的力量感很强，施鲁特空间，非常中世纪，非常英格兰。这个很有力，这个非常德怀特。安静，德怀特·施鲁特正在工作。很好。我真的听到了他的心声。这个很有趣。我不确定他是什么意思，德怀特·施鲁特，私密。很难说。珍娜，你在这一幕里真是太可爱了。
I mean, I left you a message and I was like, you would win cutest in the office, Dundee. Like, truly. My job in that scene is mostly just to look at Jim with just sparkle eyes. I'm so enamored and just so tickled, he makes me laugh, he's so funny. That was basically what I'm doing. Young actors, if you want to watch a scene on how to just be in the moment and be adorable, go watch this deleted scene.
我的意思是，我给你留了言，我说，你会赢得办公室最可爱奖，邓迪奖。真的。我在那一幕里的工作主要是用闪闪发光的眼睛看着吉姆。我非常着迷，而且被逗乐了，他让我发笑，他太搞笑了。这基本上就是我在做的事情。年轻的演员们，如果你想看一幕关于如何活在当下并表现得可爱，去看看这个删减片段吧。
Oh my gosh, you're being so sweet, Angela. It's true, I thought it was adorable. Well, in our breakdown of this episode, we talk about how this idea of Dwight taking over the conference room was a nod to the second episode of The British Office, and that Jim Pam scene that you just played, it was actually borrowed from their episode.
天哪，你太贴心了，安吉拉。这是真的，我觉得它很可爱。嗯，在我们对这一集的分析中，我们谈到了德怀特接管会议室的想法是对英国版《办公室》第二集的致敬，而你刚才播放的那个吉姆和帕姆的场景，实际上是借用了他们那一集的内容。
Don and Tim go through discarded conference room signs. It's super cute when they do it too. And here's another little tidbit. This episode ends with major cringe. Yeah. Michael has promised everyone a big surprise and everyone's pretty grumpy because they end up getting a crappy health care plan and ice cream sandwiches. Paul Lieberstein did an interview where he shared that the final scene of this healthcare episode was scripted as quote, the longest pause in television history.
唐和蒂姆翻看废弃的会议室标志。他们这样做的时候也超级可爱。还有另一个小花絮。这一集以极度的尴尬结束。是的。迈克尔向大家承诺了一个大惊喜，每个人都很生气，因为他们最终得到的是一个糟糕的医疗计划和冰淇淋三明治。保罗·利伯斯坦在一次采访中分享说，这一集医疗保健剧集的最后一幕被写成了“电视史上最长的停顿”。
Which I just love their fascination in these early seasons with creating the longest pauses. Just leaning into the awkward. Well, we had to look it up and here's how it's described in the shooting draft. I'm gonna read you the stage direction for the scene, okay? So Michael says, okay, well, I have news for you. There is a big surprise.
我真的很喜欢他们在这些早期剧集中对创造最长停顿的迷恋。只是沉浸在尴尬中。好吧，我们不得不查了一下，这是拍摄草稿中对它的描述。我要读给你听这一幕的舞台指导，好吗？所以迈克尔说，好吧，我有消息要告诉你们。有一个大惊喜。
And the big surprise, dot, dot, is dot dot dot. And here's the stage direction. We now experience the longest silent beat in network television history. Michael is blank. No one is willing to let him off the hook. We check in with everyone's expression. It's excruciating. Oscar gets fed up, puts on his coat, and drifts away. After a beat, Meredith and Angela shake their heads sadly and leave.
而这个大惊喜，点点点，是点点点。这是舞台指导。我们现在体验了电视史上最长的沉默节拍。迈克尔面无表情。没有人愿意放过他。我们观察每个人的表情。这太折磨人了。奥斯卡受够了，穿上外套，走开了。过了一会儿，梅雷迪思和安吉拉悲伤地摇了摇头，离开了。
Michael is now flop sweating a tiny bit, still silent. Kevin and Kelly drift away, followed by Toby. Stanley, as he walks out, glares at Michael. Michael turns away. Jim looks at Pam like, can you believe this? Pam stares back still upset at him. She leaves. Jim stung a bit, waits a second, and then follows her out. Slowly, everyone else leaves. Dwight is standing next to Michael. After a final beat, Dwight says, oh, um, Jan wants you to call her and Dwight walks away.
迈克尔现在出了一点冷汗，仍然沉默。凯文和凯利走开了，接着是托比。斯坦利走出去时，怒视着迈克尔。迈克尔转过身去。吉姆看着帕姆，好像在说，你敢相信吗？帕姆回视着他，仍然对他感到不满。她离开了。吉姆有点受伤，等了一秒钟，然后跟着她走了出去。慢慢地，其他人都离开了。德怀特站在迈克尔旁边。最后一次停顿后，德怀特说，哦，嗯，简让你给她回电话，然后德怀特走开了。
Yes. You know, we talk about shooting that scene in our breakdown, but I am not sure that we cover how truly impressive it is that Steve somehow manages to make himself start sweating. Yes, you feel his body, like, temperature. You, like, see him, like, him like starting to break out and like little beads of sweat. Yes, I rewatched it. It's really incredible. And we should say that while we did stand there for about two and a half minutes of silence, all just staring at him, and then we did exactly what the stage direction said, in the episode they cut back and forth to talking heads.
是的。你知道，我们在分析中谈到了拍摄那一幕，但我不知道我们是否涵盖了史蒂夫如何设法让自己开始出汗是多么令人印象深刻。是的，你能感觉到他的身体，比如，温度。你，比如，看到他，比如，他开始冒出小汗珠。是的，我重看了。这真的很不可思议。我们应该说，虽然我们确实在那里站了大约两分半钟的沉默，都盯着他看，然后我们完全按照舞台指导说的做了，但在剧集中，他们来回切换到谈话头。
So you don't really ever have like two and a half minutes of silence. Yeah, you have Michael's talking head in the middle. There is a lot of awkward silence, but I think Boo's Cruise still gets the award for longest silence on the show. Yes, not quite as cringy. But definitely uncomfortable.
所以你从来没有真正拥有过两分半钟的沉默。是的，中间有迈克尔的谈话头。有很多尴尬的沉默，但我认为《Boo's Cruise》仍然获得了该剧最长沉默的奖项。是的，没那么尴尬。但绝对不舒服。
But definitely uncomfortable silence. So there you have it, you guys. Office Ladies 6.0 is off for Thanksgiving break this week, but we will see you back next Monday for a second drink of the Alliance. And we have some fun new tidbits. I'm Jenna Fischer. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together.
但绝对是尴尬的沉默。所以，你们懂的。Office Ladies 6.0本周因感恩节假期暂停，但我们下周一会回来，带来《The Alliance》的第二杯饮料。我们还有一些有趣的新花絮。我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金赛。我们曾一起出演《办公室》。
And we're best friends. I'm Jenna Fischer. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind the scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office Ladies. Hey, welcome back to Office Ladies. It is Angela Kinsey.
我们是最好的朋友。我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金赛。我们曾一起出演《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为你制作终极办公室重温播客。每周我们将分析一集《办公室》，并提供只有两个亲历者才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女士。嘿，欢迎回到办公室女士。我是安吉拉·金赛。
And Jenna Fischer. And we're going to be talking today about health care. Hey, welcome back to Office Ladies. It is Angela Kinsey and Jenna Fisher. And we're going to be talking today about healthcare. Healthcare one of my favorite episodes from season one. I love it. I love this episode because to me it's the office at its best because it's ordinary people doing ordinary things and it all goes south. And it's big stakes because having a job that has good health care is everything. So, yes, today we are talking about season one, episode three, health care. It was written by Paul Lieberstein, who plays Toby Flenderson.
还有珍娜·费舍尔。今天我们要谈论医疗保健。嘿，欢迎回到办公室女士。我是安吉拉·金赛和珍娜·费舍尔。今天我们要谈论医疗保健。医疗保健是我第一季中最喜欢的剧集之一。我喜欢它。我喜欢这一集，因为对我来说，这是《办公室》的最佳状态，因为它是普通人在做普通的事情，而一切都变得糟糕了。而且赌注很高，因为拥有一份有良好医疗保健的工作就是一切。所以，是的，今天我们要谈论第一季第三集，医疗保健。它是由扮演托比·弗伦德森的保罗·利伯斯坦编写的。
Toby. Yes. And directed by Ken Whittingham. I love Ken. And we love Ken. Ken is the tall, gentle man. Like, he is just like so sweet and kind. Oh, you and I would talk to Ken all the time. All the time.
托比。是的。由肯·惠廷汉姆执导。我喜欢肯。我们也喜欢肯。肯是个高大、温柔的人。他就是那么甜美和善良。哦，你和我经常和肯聊天。一直都在聊。
Yeah. Probably like too much. Like he probably at some point was like, ladies, I have work to do. I have work to do. And we're like, hi, Ken. He's just so lovely. We had Ken back a lot over the entire nine seasons.
是的。可能太多了。就像他可能在某个时候说，女士们，我有工作要做。我有工作要做。我们就像，嗨，肯。他真是太可爱了。在整个九季中，我们经常请肯回来。
He directed nine episodes of The Office, including Phyllis's wedding. Yes. You just had a little bit of St. Louis there. I did. I hear it every once in a while, but you said over. Oh, is that a St. Louis thing? I don't know, but you say some words like different.
他执导了九集《办公室》，包括菲利斯的婚礼。是的。你刚才有一点圣路易斯的口音。我有。我偶尔会听到，但你说的是“over”。哦，那是圣路易斯的东西吗？我不知道，但你说的有些词很不一样。
I think it's St. Louis. The biggest St. Louis thing that I don't do, but that Phyllis does, speaking of Phyllis, is Farty Far. Oh. So we have a highway there called Highway 44. Yeah. They call it Farty Far and you eat with a farty far. So we have a highway there called Highway 44. They call it farty far and you eat with a fart. Yeah, sometimes Rain and Phyllis sat back to back,
我想是圣路易斯的。我没有做，但菲利斯做的最大的圣路易斯的事情，说到菲利斯，就是“Farty Far”。哦。所以我们在那里有一条高速公路叫44号公路。是的。他们叫它Farty Far，你用farty far吃饭。所以我们在那里有一条高速公路叫44号公路。他们叫它farty far，你用fart吃饭。是的，有时候雷恩和菲利斯背靠背坐着，
you know? And every once in a while Rain would just turn around to Phyllis and say, Phyllis say 44. And she would like, Phyllis like when she gets really tickled she snorts when she laughs. So she'd be like, farty far. Okay, all right, keep going. All right, well, let me do a summary of healthcare.
你知道吗？偶尔雷恩会转过身对菲利斯说，菲利斯，说44。她会，菲利斯就像当她被逗乐时，她笑的时候会发出哼声。所以她会说，farty far。好吧，好吧，继续。好吧，让我来总结一下医疗保健。
It's pretty simple. Jan tells Michael that he needs to pick a cheaper healthcare plan for his employees to help prevent downsizing. Michael gives the job to Dwight and then hides in his office all day because he knows no one is going to want their healthcare slashed. This is classic Michael passing the buck, which you're going to see over and over and over in the lifetime of the show.
很简单。简告诉迈克尔，他需要为员工选择一个更便宜的医疗计划，以帮助防止裁员。迈克尔把这项工作交给了德怀特，然后整天躲在办公室里，因为他知道没有人会想要他们的医疗保健被削减。这是典型的迈克尔推卸责任，你会在该剧的整个生命周期中一次又一次地看到这一点。
So after Dwight picks a plan that slashes almost all the benefits and the entire office revolts, Michael promises us a surprise. Very big. Yes. Yes, which is what you do with your children when you have to give them right bad news, but there's gonna be a surprise. It's so true.
所以德怀特选择了一个削减了几乎所有福利的计划，整个办公室都反抗了，迈克尔向我们承诺了一个惊喜。非常大。是的。是的，这就是当你不得不给孩子们带来坏消息时你会做的事情，但会有个惊喜。这太真实了。
And what I think is interesting is that everyone is skeptical, but also like, well, maybe there is a surprise. It's so sad. It could be a surprise. It's a little bit like Charlie Brown kick the football, like, you know, when Lucy kept doing that, I feel like they're like, there's no way he's going to come through. But maybe because we hate our jobs so much. So maybe there'll be something nice. Something's gonna happen. But then Michael has to spend the entire rest of the day
我认为有趣的是，每个人都持怀疑态度，但也觉得，嗯，也许真的有一个惊喜。这太可悲了。这可能是一个惊喜。这有点像查理·布朗踢足球，你知道，当露西一直那样做时，我觉得他们就像，他不可能兑现。但也许因为我们太讨厌我们的工作了。所以也许会有一些好的事情。会有什么事情发生。但迈克尔必须花剩下的整天时间
scrambling to come up with something. Yeah. And what he comes up with is. Oh, just nothing. A whole lot of nothing. Just nothing. Yes. All right, Jenna, do you wanna do some fast facts?
忙着想出点什么。是的。他想出的是。哦，只是什么都没有。一大堆什么都没有。只是什么都没有。是的。好吧，珍娜，你想做一些快问快答吗？
You know I do, Angela. I know you do. You know it. All right, so my first fast fact is that after the pilot episode, which we talked about, was pretty much a word-for-word adaptation of the British pilot, because this was a British television show before it was an American television show. After that, we started writing all original episodes. So, Diversity Day was all original. It was our
你知道我想，安吉拉。我知道你想。你知道的。好吧，所以我的第一个快问快答是，在试播集之后，我们谈过，它几乎是英国试播集的逐字改编，因为在它成为美国电视节目之前，这是一个英国电视节目。在那之后，我们开始编写所有原创剧集。所以，多元化日是完全原创的。这是我们的
story. And this is all original, with the exception of a little wink, a little nod to the British show. What? Trivia master? What? So in an episode of the British office, their Dwight character, whose name is Gareth, he gets to lead an investigation into some dirty emails that came into the office. And so he takes over the conference room and he even puts a little sign on the window. And that is the little thing that we stole for this episode is that Dwight is going to do that same thing. He's going to take over the conference room. Yes. But in this case, it is to pick a new health care plan for the company.
故事。这是完全原创的，除了一个小小的眨眼，一个小小的对英国节目的致敬。什么？琐事大师？什么？所以在英国版《办公室》的一集中，他们的德怀特角色，名字叫加雷斯，他负责调查一些进入办公室的肮脏电子邮件。所以他接管了会议室，甚至在窗户上贴了一个小标志。这就是我们为这一集偷来的小东西，德怀特也会做同样的事情。他要接管会议室。是的。但在这种情况下，是为了给公司选择一个新的医疗计划。
So we did that from time to time. We just do like these little nods to the British show, which I always think are kind of fun, especially because there were people who were huge fans of the original who were then watching our show. And that was like a little treat. Well, I like it. I like where your head's at. Starting out this episode, you like really good trivia. I like where you're going. I like it. I've got my note cards ready, lady. Do you wanna hit me with a note card or shall I continue with fast facts? No, no, no, do your fast facts.
所以我们不时这样做。我们只是对英国节目做这些小小的致敬，我一直认为这很有趣，特别是考虑到有些人是原版的忠实粉丝，他们后来在看我们的节目。那就像一个小小的款待。嗯，我喜欢它。我喜欢你的想法。开始这一集，你喜欢非常好的琐事。我喜欢你的方向。我喜欢它。我的笔记卡准备好了，女士。你想用笔记卡考我，还是我继续快问快答？不，不，不，做你的快问快答。
I got some note cards waiting for you though. All right. Well, this is a fast fact and it's actually something Angela that you pointed out. Oh, is it a Kinsey fast fact? It's a Kinsey fast fact. Okay. That this is the first time we see Devin and Creed
不过我为你准备了一些笔记卡。好吧。嗯，这是一个快问快答，实际上是你指出的，安吉拉。哦，是金赛快问快答吗？这是金赛快问快答。好吧。这是我们第一次看到德文和克里德
at their desks. Oh yes, yes. I love spotting little things in the background. You are, I'm gonna label you our background expert. No, don't, I'm not the expert. You are, but you notice those things. You really notice continuity stuff. Was it because you spent so much time
在他们的办公桌前。哦，是的，是的。我喜欢在背景中发现小东西。你，我要把你标记为我们的背景专家。不，别，我不是专家。你是，但你注意到了那些事情。你真的注意到了连续性的东西。是因为你花了很多时间
in the background, Angela? Is that a dig? No, we all did. I'm totally kidding. No, we did, but I'm like. All right, Miss Front Reception, let me tell you something. Back in accounting corner, we noticed shiitake, okay? We noticed things.
在背景里吗，安吉拉？那是挖苦吗？不，我们都做了。我完全是在开玩笑。不，我们做了，但我像。好吧，前台小姐，让我告诉你一件事。在会计角落，我们注意到了香菇，好吗？我们注意到了事情。
No, but you were always lurking back there. Lurking? So I thought, well, maybe. Now I'm a lurker? I thought maybe, you know, you're noticing more of what's happening back there. Some real truth is coming out today. You know what I noticed in this episode
不，但你总是潜伏在那里。潜伏？所以我以为，嗯，也许。现在我是潜伏者了？我以为也许，你知道，你注意到了更多在那里发生的事情。今天真相大白了。你知道我在这一集中注意到了什么吗？
that Jim has an ET on his desk. An ET doll. A little extraterrestrial doll? Yes, ET. See what I'm saying? This is a Kinsey background observation. He's wearing, he's got a little ET on his desk and the ET is wearing like a blue coat.
吉姆的桌子上有一个ET。一个ET玩偶。一个小外星人玩偶？是的，ET。明白我的意思吗？这是一个金赛背景观察。他戴着，他的桌子上有一个小ET，ET穿着一件蓝色的外套。
I have never noticed that. I know, it's at, for you guys watching, it's at 14 minutes around 35 seconds. There's an ET on Jim's desk and I'm like, what the heck? I don't remember that ET. Okay. Anyway, see if you see ET at 14 minutes. Wow. See what I'm saying?
我从来没有注意到这一点。我知道，它在，对于你们观看的人来说，它在14分35秒左右。吉姆的桌子上有一个ET，我就像，到底怎么回事？我不记得那个ET了。好吧。无论如何，看看你在14分钟时是否看到ET。哇。明白我的意思吗？
You did have a note card. I have a ton of note cards. There you go. I have more. Okay, go. All right, Angela. Here's my last fast fact. And this is something I learned when I was doing my prep for this episode and I listened
你确实有一张笔记卡。我有一吨笔记卡。给你。我还有更多。好吧，去吧。好吧，安吉拉。这是我的最后一个快问快答。这是我在为这一集做准备时学到的，我听了
to the DVD commentary. So this is the third episode of season one. However, we shot it sixth. What? Yeah. So I remember we shot the pilot and then we waited like six months to see if we got picked up Yeah And then when we did get picked up the writers had turned in like they had all their scripts ready for season one because there were
DVD评论。所以这是第一季的第三集。然而，我们拍了第六集。什么？是的。所以我记得我们拍了试播集，然后我们等了大约六个月看看我们是否被选中。是的。然后当我们被选中时，编剧们已经交了，就像他们为第一季准备好了所有的剧本，因为有
Only five more to do that's right. We only did six We did not shoot them in the same order in which they aired so when we finished this episode We all said goodbye. Oh my gosh. Do you know that? I remember that now. That puts a whole different filter on it now, like rewatching it, because I feel like we were really loosey goosey in this episode. I mean, we're going to talk about it, but a few of us just full on laugh and it's in
只有五个要做了，那是对的。我们只拍了六个。我们拍摄的顺序和播出的顺序不一样，所以当我们完成这一集时，我们都说了再见。天哪。你知道吗？我现在记得了。这现在给它加上了一个完全不同的滤镜，就像重看它一样，因为我觉得我们在这一集中真的很随意。我的意思是，我们要谈论它，但我们中的几个人只是完全笑了，它在
the episode. But we were really, we were a tight knit group by the time we were filming this. Yeah, we were all pals at this time. And I think it shows in the episode. And I think that might also be why I have such like a warm place in my heart for this episode because when we were filming this episode, we really believed, we really, really believed that this was the last one we would ever do. Oh, for sure. I thought we were not coming back at all. And I had my name, like, they printed out our name, like on paper, but then laminated it, you know, for our trailer door. Yeah, with a little bit of Velcro. That was on our trailer door. And I took my little
剧集里。但当我们拍摄这一集时，我们是一个紧密的团队。是的，我们当时都是好朋友。我认为它在剧集中表现出来了。我认为这可能也是为什么我对这一集有如此温暖的地方，因为当我们拍摄这一集时，我们真的相信，我们真的，真的相信这是我们永远做的最后一集。哦，肯定的。我以为我们根本不会回来。我把我的名字，就像，他们打印出我们的名字，就像在纸上，然后层压它，你知道，为我们的拖车门。是的，带一点魔术贴。那是在我们的拖车门上。我拿走了我的小
laminated piece of paper that said my name. I still have it. I still have it. You know what I did? What I made a mixtape. Oh, my god. I made a mixtape and I called it something like Scranton Sounds. Sounds of Scranton. Sounds of Scranton. And I gave it to John, Rain, Steve, and BJ along with a tiny homemade scrapbook of some photos. And then you said, hi, 1994 called. They want my mixtape back. I'm sure those guys were like, this is the girliest present I've ever been given. I just picture you giving that mixtape to people. And some people like they don't even have a tape player in their car.
层压纸片，上面写着我的名字。我还有它。我还有它。你知道我做了什么吗？什么，我做了一盘混音带。哦，天哪。我做了一盘混音带，我叫它类似斯克兰顿之声。斯克兰顿的声音。斯克兰顿的声音。我把它给了约翰、雷恩、史蒂夫和BJ，还有一本小小的自制剪贴簿，里面有一些照片。然后你说，嗨，1994年打来电话。他们想要回我的混音带。我敢肯定那些家伙会说，这是我收到过的最女性化的礼物。我只是想象你把那盘混音带给别人。有些人甚至在车里没有磁带播放器。
No, it was a CD. Okay. It was a mixte CD. one, it was a CD. Okay. It was a mixed CD. I call it mixed tape. Okay, I pictured an actual mixed tape. No, it wasn't a cassette. It was a CD.
不，那是一张CD。好吧。那是一张混合CD。一，那是一张CD。好吧。那是一张混合CD。我叫它混音带。好吧，我想象的是一盘真正的混音带。不，那不是磁带。那是一张CD。
I am certain if I had to bet money, I am certain no one ever listened to it. Oh. I listened to it all the time. You listened to it in your car ride because it was the sounds of Scranton for you. It was the sounds of Scranton. This is real. So my commute to where we it was the sounds of Scranton for you. It was the sounds of Scranton. This is real.
我敢肯定，如果我必须打赌，我敢肯定没有人听过它。哦。我一直听它。你在车里听它，因为那是你的斯克兰顿之声。那是斯克兰顿的声音。这是真的。所以我的通勤到我们，那是你的斯克兰顿之声。那是斯克兰顿的声音。这是真的。
So my commute to where we filmed the first season of The Office was very long. It was over an hour, because I lived in the San Fernando Valley, and we shot in Culver City. And if you live in Los Angeles or have ever been here, that is a very long commute in the morning. And I wanted to, quote unquote, get in character. So I wanted to pretend like I was driving in Scranton.
所以我的通勤到我们拍摄《办公室》第一季的地方非常长。超过一个小时，因为我住在圣费尔南多谷，我们在卡尔弗城拍摄。如果你住在洛杉矶或者曾经来过这里，那早上通勤时间很长。我想，引用，进入角色。所以我想假装我在斯克兰顿开车。
So I wanted some sounds in Scranton. So I wanted some sounds of Scranton. Did you like research what people were listening to in Scranton? I didn't. How do you know these were the sounds of Scranton? You know what? I really don't. I'm going to say I made a lot of assumptions. And I kind of went back to my college days. And I had some classic rock, back to my college days and I had some classic rock and a little bit of Garth Brooks. But now that I'm saying it, I realize I don't really know what East Coast people listen to. I was so whatever. It put me in a head space. Okay. Well, I just want you to know, I want the Sounds of Scranton on our website. I'm going to look for it.
所以我想要一些斯克兰顿的声音。所以我想要一些斯克兰顿的声音。你喜欢研究人们在斯克兰顿听什么吗？我没有。你怎么知道这些是斯克兰顿的声音？你知道吗？我真的不知道。我要说我做了很多假设。我有点回到我的大学时代。我有一些经典摇滚，回到我的大学时代，我有一些经典摇滚和一点加斯·布鲁克斯。但现在我说了，我意识到我真的不知道东海岸的人听什么。我太随便了。它让我进入了一个头脑空间。好吧。好吧，我只是想让你知道，我想要斯克兰顿的声音在我们的网站上。我会找它的。
I want the playlist. I bet I still have it. Also, I wanna know if it was a CD. It's gonna be embarrassing. If it was a CD, I wanna know, did you make a little cover and write out each song or did you type them out and print it? Is there a photo?
我想要播放列表。我敢打赌我还有它。另外，我想知道它是否是一张CD。这会很尴尬。如果它是一张CD，我想知道，你做了一个小封面并写下了每一首歌，还是你打印出来并打印了它？有一张照片吗？
What's the cover of the CD? The cover of the CD is a collage of different pictures that remind me of Scranton. Wait, wait, wait. And it's printed on the back. Wait, no, no, no. No, wait. Please stop.
CD的封面是什么？CD的封面是不同照片的拼贴画，让我想起斯克兰顿。等等，等等，等等。它印在背面。等等，不，不，不。不，等等。请停止。
Please stop. These aren't photos of people on the show. No. They're images of Scranton that you got from the computer, you got from the internet. And it's a collage. And so they're photos of Scranton. Yes. And it's called Sounds of Scranton.
请停止。这些不是剧组人员的照片。不。它们是你从电脑上得到的斯克兰顿的图像，你从互联网上得到的。这是一个拼贴画。所以它们是斯克兰顿的照片。是的。它叫斯克兰顿之声。
Right. You are the biggest dork I know. And I would listen to it on my drive to get into the character of Pam. Oh my God. And then I would go to work. This is all why I love you. This is why I love you.
对。你是我认识的最大的书呆子。我会听它在我的车里进入帕姆的角色。哦，天哪。然后我会去上班。这就是为什么我爱你。这就是为什么我爱你。
Because I wanna be best friends with a person that prints images of places in Scranton. It makes a collage. And then it makes up a CD. Oh my God. As I'm telling this story now, it's occurring to me that when you live in a city, you don't make a tribute CD of the city you live in.
因为我想和一个打印斯克兰顿地方图像的人成为最好的朋友。它制作了一个拼贴画。然后它制作了一张CD。哦，天哪。当我讲这个故事时，我想到当你住在一个城市时，你不会为你居住的城市制作一张致敬CD。
Like I lived in St. Louis my whole life and I never drove around with a CD called Sounds of St. Louis. Well, I'm going to now, Sounds of Los Angeles. Ooh, let's make it. I didn't know what to I'm going to now. Sounds of Los Angeles. It's going to happen. I didn't know what to give as a wrap gift. That's a thing. Do people know that?
就像我一生都住在圣路易斯，我从来没有开着一张叫圣路易斯之声的CD到处跑。好吧，我现在要做了，洛杉矶之声。哦，让我们做吧。我不知道，我现在要做了。洛杉矶之声。它会发生的。我不知道送什么作为包装礼物。那是一回事。人们知道吗？
When you finish a series, when you finish a season of a show, it's sort of customary to give out little presents to your cast members or to some of your crew members. And so I really did not know what to give out. You know, Kate Flannery, I give out Sounds of Scranton. Kate Flannery had these Dunder Mifflin candles made. Do you remember that? I have it.
当你完成一个系列，当你完成一个节目的季节时，给你的演员或你的一些工作人员送小礼物是习惯。所以我真的不知道送什么。你知道，凯特·弗兰纳里，我送出斯克兰顿之声。凯特·弗兰纳里制作了这些邓德·米夫林蜡烛。你记得吗？我有它。
I still have it. I have it. Yeah, and she gave out like a Dunder Mifflin candle. But we really gifted. We were like, we're done. I got everyone to sign my script. So I still have that, and that's really cool. And Kate gave me a photo of her and I standing at our trailers,
我还有它。我有它。是的，她送出了像邓德·米夫林蜡烛。但我们真的很有天赋。我们就像，我们完成了。我让每个人都在我的剧本上签名。所以我还有那个，那真的很酷。凯特给了我一张她和我站在我们的拖车旁的照片，
because we shared a trailer. Kate and I had a trailer, and just the only thing between our toilets was like a plastic accordion door. So if I sat on my toilet and she sat on hers, our knees touched. So we made a vow to never use our toilets. We were like, we just can't.
因为我们共用一个拖车。凯特和我有一个拖车，我们厕所之间唯一的东西就是像塑料手风琴门。所以如果我坐在我的马桶上，她坐在她的马桶上，我们的膝盖碰到了。所以我们发誓永远不要使用我们的马桶。我们就像，我们只是不能。
We can't, that's just not gonna happen. I remember that. You remember our plastic accordion door? I do. It can't. That's just not going to happen. I remember that. You remember our plastic accordion door? I do. It didn't even really shut. So we just opened it and just shared basically one room with two toilets. Well, when I think back to that time,
我们不能，那只是不会发生。我记得那个。你记得我们的塑料手风琴门吗？我记得。那只是不会发生。你记得我们的塑料手风琴门吗？我记得。它甚至没有真正关上。所以我们只是打开它，基本上共用一个有两个马桶的房间。好吧，当我回想起那个时候，
I remember having anxiety about, I mean, I've just had the most thrilling experience of my acting life. I had been a struggling actor for eight years before I got my job on the office. I'd never had a regular role on anything. I'd done pilots, but they never got picked up. So this was my first series. And I thought, well, what do I do?
我记得对，我的意思是，我刚刚经历了我的演艺生涯中最激动人心的经历。在我得到《办公室》的工作之前，我做了八年的挣扎演员。我从来没有在任何事情上担任过常规角色。我做过试播集，但它们从来没有被选中。所以这是我的第一个系列。我想，好吧，我该怎么办？
If this show gets canceled, I guess I just go back to the beginning. I mean, we could have all had to go back and get day jobs again. I mean, we could have all had to go back and get day jobs again. I mean, so Kate Flannery and I both, we did not quit our day jobs for the first season of The Office. Oh, I remember that.
如果这个节目被取消了，我想我只是回到开始。我的意思是，我们可能都不得不回去再找日常工作。我的意思是，我们可能都不得不回去再找日常工作。我的意思是，所以凯特·弗兰纳里和我，我们没有在《办公室》第一季辞掉我们的日常工作。哦，我记得那个。
Kate Flannery was still a waitress at Kate Manolini in Beverly Hills. And so she would work on The Office and then she'd go wait tables. I remember that. Yeah, and I was working at iOS, which is an improv theater, and I was helping run the office and I stayed on and would help.
凯特·弗兰纳里仍然是比佛利山庄凯特·曼诺里尼的女服务员。所以她会在《办公室》工作，然后她会去等桌子。我记得那个。是的，我在iOS工作，这是一个即兴剧院，我帮忙经营办公室，我留下来帮忙。
Yeah. I just would have gone back to helping run a theater and improv classes. And I ran the intern program. I fired someone who's now famous, one of my interns. Who? Can you say? He's a lovable person and I love him. Tell me. So this was my intern who was always late. He was always late. The higher ups said, okay, you can be late three times
是的。我本来会回去帮忙经营一个剧院和即兴表演课。我解雇了一个现在很有名的人，我的一个实习生。谁？你能说吗？他是一个可爱的人，我爱他。告诉我。所以这是我的实习生，他总是迟到。他总是迟到。高层说，好吧，你可以迟到三次
and then you get fired. And so I- As an intern, his job was to keep the restroom clean. He had to come early, set up the box office. Okay. Like we needed him there early. And he was late a lot, but I really liked him. And then finally they were like,
然后你被解雇了。所以作为一名实习生，他的工作是保持洗手间清洁。他必须早点来，设置票房。好吧。就像我们需要他早点到那里。他经常迟到，但我真的很喜欢他。然后最后他们就像，
you're gonna have to fire him. So he walks in one day and his name is Derek Waters. Creator of drunk history. Creator of drunk history. And he walked in and he was really late and I was like, hey, Derek. And he's like, hey, Angela, are you gonna fire me today? And I was like, I am. And he goes, okay. Oh my gosh, Angela, he told me this story. I wrote a book, everyone plug, My gosh, Angela, he told me this story. I wrote a book, everyone plug,
你得解雇他。所以他有一天走进来，他的名字是德里克·沃特斯。醉酒历史的创造者。醉酒历史的创造者。他走进来，他真的很迟到，我就像，嘿，德里克。他说，嘿，安吉拉，你今天要解雇我吗？我就像，我是。他说，好吧。哦，天哪，安吉拉，他告诉了我这个故事。我写了一本书，每个人都插播，天哪，安吉拉，他告诉了我这个故事。我写了一本书，每个人都插播，
The Actor's Life, a Survival Guide. Check it out. Local books. Nice flex. Local bookstores, check it out. I wrote a book and I interviewed Derek in the book and he told me the story of being fired from I.O. I did not know it was you that fired him.
演员的生活，生存指南。看看吧。当地书店。不错的灵活。当地书店，看看吧。我写了一本书，我在书中采访了德里克，他告诉我从I.O.被解雇的故事。我不知道是你解雇了他。
It was me. Well, it's still very much on his mind because he mentioned it in an interview. I know, but anyway, I would just go back to running a theater basically. I have something. So I know healthcare is about the office, finding a good healthcare plan and the downsizing.
是我。好吧，这仍然在他的脑海中，因为他在一次采访中提到了它。我知道，但无论如何，我基本上会回去经营一个剧院。我有一些东西。所以我知道医疗保健是关于办公室的，找到一个好的医疗计划和裁员。
I know the overall arc of this episode, but I just want you to know, I have started calling this episode, the Pam Sass. The Pam Sass? Uh-huh, and it's gonna have started calling this episode the Pam Sass. The Pam Sass? Uh-huh and it's gonna come up throughout this episode where Pam is super sassy. Well, well. Uh-huh it starts off right away when Michael comes up to you and you say I'm not making any copies. Like you're sassy out of the gate lady and then then you say oh do you want me to repeat the messages for the,
我知道这一集的整体弧线，但我只是想让你知道，我已经开始称这一集为，帕姆萨斯。帕姆萨斯？嗯哼，它会开始称这一集为帕姆萨斯。帕姆萨斯？嗯哼，它会出现在这一集中，帕姆超级无礼。好吧，好吧。嗯哼，当迈克尔走到你面前时，它立刻就开始了，你说我不会做任何复印。就像你从大门出来就很无礼，女士，然后你说，哦，你想让我重复这些信息吗？
and you look to camera? I have many more as we go through this episode. What were you? Did I piss you off before you watched this episode? No. And then you're just looking for sass moments? I am not. Listen, you re-watch it, and right away, you're just like,
你看着镜头？当我浏览这一集时，我还有很多。你是什么？我在你看这一集之前惹你生气了吗？不。然后你只是在寻找无礼的时刻？我不是。听着，你重看它，立刻，你就像，
you are here. You are not here to mess around. You try having a boss like Michael Scott and see what kind of mood it puts you in. Well you were sassy in this one. I was matter of fact. Pam sass. Oh my goodness. Okay go, go on. What's out? What else is there? That's it. All right lady I think we should take a break. I think we should but I think we should tell everyone that when we come back from our break we're gonna have a special guest. Well I think you just told them. I did. It's gonna be a tall drink of water. Mm-hmm.
你在这里。你不是来搞砸的。你试着有一个像迈克尔·斯科特这样的老板，看看它让你处于什么样的心情。好吧，你在这一集中很无礼。我实事求是。帕姆萨斯。哦，天哪。好吧，去吧，继续。还有什么？就是这样。好吧，女士，我想我们应该休息一下。我想我们应该，但我认为我们应该告诉大家，当我们从休息中回来时，我们会有一个特别嘉宾。好吧，我想你刚刚告诉他们了。我做了。它会是一杯高大的水。嗯哼。
Mr. Rainn Wilson. Yes! Hamburglar, why are you calling? Rubble, rubble. McDonald's has a new biggest burger called Big Arch, made with two 100% Canadian beef patties a new delicious sauce and all the McDonald's flavors you love and wait you want me to help you get it? Rubble come on
雷恩·威尔逊先生。是的！汉堡神偷，你为什么要打电话？Rubble, rubble。麦当劳推出了一款全新的超大汉堡，名叫Big Arch，它由两块100%加拿大牛肉饼、一种全新的美味酱汁以及你所钟爱的所有麦当劳风味制成，等等，你想让我帮你买到它？Rubble，来吧。
Compared to beef burgers on McDonald's current menu at participating restaurants in Canada Welcome to the oil business Billy Bob Thornton to me Moore and Jon Hamm star in a new Paramount Plus original series. The world has already convinced itself that you are evil and I am evil for providing them the one thing they interact with every day. You're all right, here we go. From Taylor Sheridan, executive producer of Yellowstone. Get everybody back. You just put a giant bulls eye on this place.
与加拿大参与活动的餐厅中麦当劳当前菜单上的牛肉汉堡相比。欢迎来到石油业务，比利·鲍勃·桑顿、黛米·摩尔和乔恩·哈姆主演了一部新的派拉蒙+原创系列。世界已经说服自己你是邪恶的，而我因为为他们提供他们每天互动的一件事而邪恶。你没事，我们开始吧。来自泰勒·谢里丹，黄石公园的执行制片人。让每个人回来。你刚刚在这个地方放了一个巨大的靶心。
We rolled the dice one last time. Get everybody back! Go! Go! You just put a giant bullseye on this place. We rolled the dice one last time. Landman, new series now streaming exclusively on Paramount+. The faster money and data move, the further your business can go to a seamless digital future for Canadians. Let's go faster forward together. In Life, Interact. It's time to break down the health care episode.
我们最后一次掷骰子。让每个人回来！走！走！你刚刚在这个地方放了一个巨大的靶心。我们最后一次掷骰子。Landman，新系列现在在派拉蒙+独家流媒体播放。金钱和数据移动得越快，你的业务就能越远地走向加拿大人无缝的数字未来。让我们一起更快地前进。在生活中，互动。是时候分解医疗保健剧集了。
Let's do it. All right, we're going to go a little rogue here. OK. We're going to do a phone call with Rainn Wilson. With Rainn Wilson! Yeah, there were just too many things about this episode that were Dwight centered and we had a lot of questions from fans that I think we needed to go straight to the source. We agreed. We agreed and Rainn said yes and we're so thrilled so we're gonna talk to Rainn. We're gonna call him. Let's call
让我们做吧。好吧，我们要在这里有点流氓。好的。我们要和雷恩·威尔逊通电话。和雷恩·威尔逊！是的，关于这一集有太多的事情是以德怀特为中心的，我们有很多来自粉丝的问题，我认为我们需要直接找到源头。我们同意了。我们同意了，雷恩说好，我们非常激动，所以我们要和雷恩谈谈。我们要给他打电话。让我们给
Rainn. Let's call Rain. Hello. Is this Rainn Wilson? Hey Rainn. It is Rainn Wilson. Rainn Wilson? It's Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. What's up fella?
雷恩打电话。让我们给雷恩打电话。你好。这是雷恩·威尔逊吗？嘿，雷恩。这是雷恩·威尔逊。雷恩·威尔逊？我是珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛。怎么了，伙计？
How are you? Thanks for doing this. I'm great guys. Yeah? I'm really good. I'm launching a podcast this week called Metaphysical Milkshake. Oh! And I'm doing that with Reza Aslan.
你好吗？谢谢你做这件事。我很好，伙计们。是吗？我真的很好。我本周推出了一个播客，叫形而上奶昔。哦！我和礼萨·阿斯兰一起做那个。
And is this in coordination with SoulPancake? It is, yes. And it's a podcast that's going to be a podcast about the soul of the soul. And it's a podcast that's going to be a podcast about the soul of the soul. And it's a podcast that's going to be a podcast about the soul of the soul. And it's a podcast that's going to be a podcast about the soul of the soul. And it's a podcast that's going to be a podcast about the soul of the soul. And it's a podcast that's going to be a podcast about the soul of the soul.
这是与SoulPancake协调的吗？是的，是的。这是一个播客，它将是一个关于灵魂的灵魂的播客。这是一个播客，它将是一个关于灵魂的灵魂的播客。这是一个播客，它将是一个关于灵魂的灵魂的播客。这是一个播客，它将是一个关于灵魂的灵魂的播客。这是一个播客，它将是一个关于灵魂的灵魂的播客。这是一个播客，它将是一个关于灵魂的灵魂的播客。
And it's a podcast that's going to be a podcast about the soul of the soul. And it's a podcast that's going to be a podcast about the soul of the soul. And it's a podcast that's going to be a podcast about the soul of the soul. And it's a podcast that's going to be a podcast about the soul of the soul. And it's a podcast that's going to be a podcast about week called Metaphysical Milkshake and I'm doing that with Reza Aslan. And is this in coordination with SoulPancake? It is, yes. And it's life's big questions of philosophy and psychology and spirituality and sociology and we're talking to some of the world's greatest minds with some super interesting stories. I love that. And that launches very soon. That is so. I love that. That launches very soon. That is so you, Rain.
这是一个播客，它将是一个关于灵魂的灵魂的播客。这是一个播客，它将是一个关于灵魂的灵魂的播客。这是一个播客，它将是一个关于灵魂的灵魂的播客。这是一个播客，它将是一个关于灵魂的灵魂的播客。这是一个播客，它将是一个关于灵魂的灵魂的播客，叫形而上奶昔，我和礼萨·阿斯兰一起做那个。这是与SoulPancake协调的吗？是的，是的。这是关于哲学、心理学、灵性和社会学的生活大问题，我们正在与一些世界上最伟大的思想家谈论一些超级有趣的故事。我喜欢那个。它很快就会推出。那太。我喜欢那个。它很快就会推出。那太像你了，雷恩。
That is so great. You are the person I go to with all of those questions in life. We can tell people I have called you on occasion sobbing. You are my person that I trust with those big life moments. So this makes total sense. That's so sweet. It's true. That's so sweet.
那太棒了。你是我带着生活中所有这些问题去找的人。我们可以告诉人们，我偶尔会哭着给你打电话。你是我信任那些重大生活时刻的人。所以这完全说得通。那太甜了。这是真的。那太甜了。
And I call you anytime I have an issue in the kitchen or anything with cooking or bread related. I will say this though, Rain you know what I love is that you do reach out to Jenna and I in times when you're definitely like wanting like love and support and I love that we are all there for each other like that. It's true. Yeah. You guys are like the sisters that I never had. Aw, you're too, we've talked about you a little bit, like how you would look at us and say like, look at them. They just like, they're two hens, like cluck cluck cluck cluck cluck. They will not stop talking.
我随时给你打电话，如果我在厨房里有什么问题，或者任何与烹饪或面包有关的事情。不过我会说，雷恩，你知道我喜欢的是，你确实在你想得到爱和支持的时候联系珍娜和我，我喜欢我们都像那样为彼此存在。这是真的。是的。你们就像我从未有过的姐妹。噢，你们太，我们谈论过你一点，就像你会看着我们说，看她们。她们就像，她们是两只母鸡，咯咯咯咯咯。她们不会停止说话。
Blah blah blah. Blah blah blah. I mean, if the listeners could only know what those conversations were like on the set. I mean, it's just like, I made the best lasagna. You did, I love lasagna. One time I went to Italy, I had lasagna. You know you went to Italy?
叽叽喳喳。叽叽喳喳。我的意思是，如果听众只能知道片场上的那些对话是什么样的。我的意思是，就像，我做了最好的烤宽面条。你做了，我喜欢烤宽面条。有一次我去意大利，我吃了烤宽面条。你知道你去过意大利吗？
I've been to Spain once. I like Spain. Spain is so handsome. Do you like ham? I love ham. They had a handful on you. They weren't even that interesting, Rainn. They weren't even that interesting.
我去过一次西班牙。我喜欢西班牙。西班牙太棒了。你喜欢火腿吗？我爱火腿。他们手里拿着火腿。他们甚至没那么有趣，雷恩。他们甚至没那么有趣。
That's way more interesting. That is like way more fascinating than anything we ever talked about for hours on end. That's fantastic. It's so true. Okay, well we have some questions for you about the healthcare episode. We do.
那可有趣多了。那比我们几个小时以来谈论的任何事情都要迷人得多。太棒了。确实如此。好吧，关于医疗保健那一集，我们有一些问题要问你。我们确实有。
All right. Go. So we're talking to you about the healthcare episode, which is appropriate because this is a Dwight A storyline. Big storyline. Big storyline. Your first real big one, right? Wow, thanks guys. Thanks for the support.
好的。问吧。所以我们要和你聊聊医疗保健那一集，这很合适，因为这是德怀特的一条主线。大主线。大主线。这是你第一个真正的大主线，对吧？哇，谢谢你们。谢谢你们的支持。
Yeah. From 2004. Yeah, thank you. Hey, you did some great stuff a decade ago. No, I'm kidding. It's true. All right, so I wanna ask you, Rain, just what comes to mind for you
是的。从2004年开始。是的，谢谢。嘿，你十年前做了一些很棒的事情。不，我开玩笑的。这是真的。好吧，我想问你，雷恩，当你第一次想到医疗保健那一集时，你脑子里会想到什么？
when you first think of the healthcare episode? That was the first episode that I remember that we spent an inordinate amount of time in the conference room. Yeah. And I remember saying hot dog fingers. Hot dog fingers. Which totally made us break
那是第一个我记得我们在会议室里花了大量时间的剧集。是的。我记得我说过“热狗手指”。热狗手指。这让我们完全笑场了
and they left it in the episode. Rainn, I full on start laughing and then Brian breaks character and points to me and starts laughing and it's still in the episode. Rain, I full on start laughing. And then Brian breaks character and points to me and starts laughing. And it's still in the episode. That is your real laughing in that. That's me really laughing. It's true.
他们把它留在了剧集里。雷恩，我完全笑出来了，然后布莱恩打破了角色，指着我开始笑，这仍然在剧集里。雷恩，我完全笑出来了。然后布莱恩打破了角色，指着我开始笑。这仍然在剧集里。那是你真实的笑声。那确实是我在笑。这是真的。
They left in the edit, you guys breaking, you guys cracking over these diseases. And it's truly hysterical. But I do remember saying to Kate Flannery, didn't I say like, you had your vagina moved and she's like, it was a hysterectomy, it was my uterus or something like that? I still have a vagina. Yes, that was in the conference room.
他们留下了剪辑，你们因为这些疾病而笑场。这真的太搞笑了。但我确实记得我对凯特·弗兰纳里说，我不是说“你的阴道被移位了”吗？她说，那是子宫切除术，是我的子宫之类的？我还有阴道。是的，那是在会议室里。
But when you first come out, this is a frequently asked fan question, which is did you guys improvise the fake diseases or were they scripted? And I remember that there were scripted fake diseases. But then at a certain point, just Paul and the director and other writers came down and they were just handing you a piece of paper with improvised fake diseases. And none of us knew you were going to say hot dog fingers. It was a complete and utter surprise that was not in the script. Do you remember that? Yes. So that's exactly, there were some very funny ones that were scripted and nano robot
但当你第一次出来时，这是一个粉丝经常问的问题，就是你们是即兴发挥了那些虚构的疾病，还是照着剧本演的？我记得确实有剧本写的虚构疾病。但在某个时候，保罗和导演以及其他编剧下来了，他们只是递给你一张写着即兴虚构疾病的纸。我们谁也没想到你会说“热狗手指”。那是一个完全的惊喜，剧本里没有。你记得吗？是的。所以就是这样，有一些非常有趣的疾病是剧本写的，还有纳米机器人
micro invasion or whatever that one was. Right. That was in there and a lot of great ones were in there. But yeah, they kept feeding the other ones. It was very hard for me to keep a straight face. I broke all the parts. I know. I remember thinking, how are we gonna have any usable takes? I didn't know. Because we all kept laughing. You know, you get to a certain point in laughing
微型入侵之类的。对。那就在里面，很多很棒的都在里面。但是的，他们一直在喂我其他的。我很难保持严肃。我把所有部分都演砸了。我知道。我记得当时在想，我们怎么能有可用的镜头？我不知道。因为我们一直在笑。你知道，当你笑到一定程度时
when you just cross a line where you've just been tickled too much and you just can't bring it back. Yes. That happened. You know, that happened maybe like, I won't say every episode, but every two to three episodes, that kind of happened for me,
当你越过了一条线，被逗得太厉害，就再也回不来了。是的。那发生了。你知道，那可能每两三集就会发生一次，对我来说就是这样，
and it absolutely happened in this one. But my friend Kevin, Kevin Isola, who's an actor in New York, he was visiting the set, and he was the one who actually threw out Hot Dog Fingers. Oh my gosh, that's amazing. Kevin! That's his claim to fame, yeah.
这一集绝对发生了。但我朋友凯文，凯文·伊索拉，他是纽约的一名演员，他当时在片场参观，是他提出了“热狗手指”。天哪，太神奇了。凯文！那是他的成名作，是的。
His claim, I hope he has a shirt that just says Hot Dog Fingers. I hope he has a shirt that just says hot dog fingers. I mean, I feel like we- I am going to buy him that shirt right now. Send that to him. That would be a really good shirt. It would be. Wouldn't it?
他的成名作，我希望他有一件写着“热狗手指”的衬衫。我希望他有一件写着“热狗手指”的衬衫。我的意思是，我觉得我们——我现在就要给他买那件衬衫。寄给他。那会是一件非常好的衬衫。会是的。不是吗？
Yeah, hot dog fingers. Rain, you have one of my favorite talking heads in this episode. I mean, there's so many. You have so many good ones over the years. But this is like the one, definitely season one that is like. It sort of is like the quintessential in for Dwight. Yes, it's the lion, your whole like,
是的，热狗手指。雷恩，这一集里有我最喜欢的你的访谈片段之一。我的意思是，有很多。多年来你有很多好的片段。但这绝对是第一季里最典型的德怀特时刻。是的，就是那段关于在野外，野外没有医疗保健，
like your whole rant about in the wild, there is no healthcare in the wild healthcare is, ow, I hurt my leg. Should we play it? Do you want us to play it, Rain? We have that ability here. We're really high tech. Yeah, I love it.
你关于在野外没有医疗保健的咆哮，医疗保健是，哎哟，我伤了腿。我们要放出来吗？你想让我们放出来吗，雷恩？我们这里有这个能力。我们真的很先进。是的，我喜欢。
Yeah, I'd love to hear it. You wanna listen to yourself deliver a great talking head? I do. In the wild, there is no healthcare. In the wild, healthcare is, ow, I hurt my leg. I can't run. A lion eats me and I'm dead. Wow.
是的，我很想听听。你想听听自己发表一段精彩的访谈吗？我想。在野外，没有医疗保健。在野外，医疗保健是，哎哟，我伤了腿。我跑不动了。狮子吃了我，我就死了。哇。
I'm not dead. I'm the lion. You're dead. I love that so much. Oh my gosh. The only thing I'll say about that one was, you know, we were really establishing Dwight and his logic and how seriously he took himself and these kind of rules that Dwight started to develop where he's very hierarchical and status and like this is how things must be done.
我没死。我是狮子。你死了。我太喜欢那个了。天哪。关于那一段，我唯一要说的是，你知道，我们当时真的在确立德怀特和他的逻辑，以及他对自己有多认真，还有德怀特开始制定的那些规则，他非常讲究等级和地位，就像事情必须这样完成一样。
But he has a completely different set of rules than other people do. Just how he sees the world. And so one of the things I think that has given the character enduring appeal is, um, he sees the world in a very clear way with these kind of stratus stratum stratum hierarchies of rights and wrongs and moralities and how things work and how they should work. And he's they're very severe.
但他有一套与其他人完全不同的规则。这就是他看待世界的方式。所以我认为赋予这个角色持久吸引力的一件事是，嗯，他以一种非常清晰的方式看待世界，有着这种关于对错、道德以及事情如何运作和应该如何运作的阶层等级。而且它们非常严厉。
And this is one of the first talking heads that kind of like dove, delved into that world of Dwight. And it's all Paul Lieberstein. He wrote that and he was very happy with it. He was so excited to kind of help, he really helped direct. He wasn't directing the episode, but he was right there kind of getting a ton of notes on different inflections and ways to say it.
这是第一批深入德怀特那个世界的访谈片段之一。这全是保罗·利伯斯坦的功劳。他写了那段，他对此非常满意。他很高兴能帮忙，他真的帮忙指导了。他没有执导这一集，但他就在那里，对不同的语调和表达方式给出了大量的建议。
Oh, wow. Interesting. Interesting. Okay. This is totally random, but, Rain, in rewatching this, during that talking head, you're passing out the new healthcare plan. You're tossing it to people. You're handing it around the office. And it looks like you have a lollipop in your mouth.
哦，哇。有趣。有趣。好吧。这完全是随机的，但是，雷恩，在重看这一集时，在那段访谈中，你正在分发新的医疗保健计划。你把它扔给人们。你在办公室里传阅它。看起来你嘴里含着棒棒糖。
There is a white stick sticking out of your mouth as you're passing all these papers out. Angela, you should know something about this podcast, Rain, which is that Angela is constantly picking up on these weird little details. Well, I'm just like, what the heck? When I rewatch, I'm like, does Rain, as Dwight, are you sucking on a lollipop as you're passing this out? Because that's brilliant. I have no memory of that whatsoever, but I think maybe I was. Yeah. Well, look around four minutes, 50 seconds. You're like have it looks like a lollipop in your mouth. Did you hear that? Four minutes, 30 seconds. No, 50, around 50 seconds. 50 seconds. You're just like flippantly passing these papers though, sucking on a lollipop. I thought it was really cool and powerful.
当你分发这些文件时，你嘴里伸出一根白色的棍子。安吉拉，关于这个播客你应该知道一件事，雷恩，那就是安吉拉一直在捕捉这些奇怪的小细节。好吧，我只是想，到底怎么回事？当我重看时，我在想，雷恩，作为德怀特，你在分发这些东西时是在吸棒棒糖吗？因为那太天才了。我对此毫无记忆，但我想也许我是在吸。是的。好吧，看看四分五十秒左右。你看起来嘴里像含着棒棒糖。你听到了吗？四分三十秒。不，50，50秒左右。50秒。你只是漫不经心地分发这些文件，同时吸着棒棒糖。我觉得这真的很酷，很有力量。
I don't know. I loved it. Well, this leads us into the scene with Jim and Pam confronting you about, confronting Dwight about picking a horrible plan where he slashed all the benefits. You have all those other great Dwightisms where you say you've never been sick, that you have an amazing immune system to which we ask you how can you have a great immune system
我不知道。我喜欢它。好吧，这引出了吉姆和帕姆与你对质的场景，关于德怀特选择了一个糟糕的计划，削减了所有福利。你有所有那些其他伟大的“德怀特主义”，你说你从来没生过病，你有惊人的免疫系统，对此我们问你，你怎么能有伟大的免疫系统
if you've never been sick and it's just you have great genes and that's when you say that you can raise and lower your cholesterol at will. At will. And I say, why would you want to raise your cholesterol? And you say, so I can lower it? I remember shooting that scene with you and I remember that was the couplet
如果你从来没生过病，那只是因为你有很好的基因，那就是你说你可以随意升高和降低胆固醇的时候。随意。我说，你为什么要升高胆固醇？你说，这样我就可以降低它？我记得和你拍那场戏，我记得那是那句对白
that I couldn't get through. Why would you, that was the couplet that I couldn't get through. Why would you? That was the one that got me. And that was a question from a fan, actually. Christopher said, how many times did it take for you and Rain to get through the cholesterol scene? And I can't remember how many times, but it was a lot, Christopher.
我无法顺利说出来。为什么你会，那是那句我无法顺利说出来的对白。为什么你会？那是让我笑场的那一句。这其实是一个粉丝的问题。克里斯托弗问，你和雷恩拍胆固醇那场戏拍了多少次？我不记得多少次了，但很多次，克里斯托弗。
Yeah, it's funny how in history, looking back on The Office, there are these quotes that pop out that become like the classic quotes of the character. And it's interesting that, you know, for Dwight, there's like 15 or 20 kind of Dwightisms that stand the test of time and that fans love to, you know, identity theft is not a joke, Jim, you know, some of these ones, and the cholesterol one is definitely one of them. I feel like another one of those phrases
是的，回顾《办公室》的历史，有一些引语跳出来成为角色的经典引语，这很有趣。有趣的是，你知道，对于德怀特来说，有15到20种经得起时间考验的“德怀特主义”，粉丝们喜欢，你知道，“身份盗窃不是玩笑，吉姆”，你知道，其中一些，胆固醇那句绝对是其中之一。我觉得还有另一个短语
that people talk about is the count choculatus, the scene where you are confronting Jim, but also something that ended up on the cutting room floor from this where you actually had meetings with a bunch of people in the office. confronting Jim, but also something that ended up on the cutting room floor from this were you actually had meetings with a bunch of people in the office. You shot something where you confronted Oscar. I think you had a meeting with him, didn't you, Angela?
人们谈论的是“巧克力伯爵”，你与吉姆对质的场景，但这一集里还有一些最终被剪掉的东西，你实际上在办公室里和很多人开了会。你拍了一些你与奥斯卡对质的东西。我想你和他开过会，不是吗，安吉拉？
And it was very short. Probably, yeah. Where he asks you if you wrote the fake diseases, because he goes through and interviews people. Well, in your interview with Jim, you say Count Choculatus. Why did you write that down, Jim? Is it because you know I love Count Chocula? I love the idea that you love Count Chocula,
而且非常短。可能是吧。他问你是否写了那些虚构的疾病，因为他去采访了人们。好吧，在你的采访中，吉姆说“巧克力伯爵”。你为什么要写下那个，吉姆？是因为你知道我喜欢巧克力伯爵吗？我喜欢你喜欢巧克力伯爵的想法，
that that's what Dwight has for breakfast in the mornings, or maybe late at night while he's watching TV. Yeah, maybe it's a snack. Maybe he models himself after Count Chocula. Maybe there's a, he has an affinity for Count Chocula, the character, the person behind the cereal. Yeah, yeah, not even the cereal. It's not the cereal.
那是德怀特早上吃的早餐，或者也许是深夜看电视时吃的。是的，也许是零食。也许他以巧克力伯爵为榜样。也许他，他对巧克力伯爵这个角色，麦片背后的那个人有亲近感。是的，是的，甚至不是麦片。不是麦片。
That's right. He loves Count Chocula, the cereal, the person. Yeah, he's more disconnected to actual Count Chocula. He relates to him. Yeah. Yeah. Well, you brought it up earlier. There's also the conference room scene when you start announcing ailments
没错。他喜欢巧克力伯爵，那个麦片，那个人。是的，他与真正的巧克力伯爵更疏远。他与他有共鸣。是的。是的。好吧，你之前提到了。还有会议室场景，当你开始宣布疾病时
and you tell us that if we want it covered, we have to fess up and admit that it's a real disease. And that's when you have that bit with Meredith where she says, you say inverted penis. She's like, she said, do you mean vagina? Because if so, I want that covered. And then you bring up, I thought you didn't have a vagina, you had a hysterectomy.
你告诉我们，如果我们想要保险覆盖，我们必须坦白并承认这是一种真正的疾病。那就是你和梅雷迪思的那段戏，她说，你说“阴道倒置”。她说，你是说阴道吗？如果是这样，我想要那个保险覆盖。然后你提出来，我以为你没有阴道，你做了子宫切除术？
And then she has that great line. I still have a vagina. Yeah, I think I improvised that. And this was early on, we started to kind of like, improvise a little bit more. Wait, you improvised that she had a hysterectomy? Did you improvise that because that pays off later in another episode? No, no, no, no, no.
然后她说了那句很棒的台词。“我还有阴道。”是的，我想我是即兴发挥的。这是早期，我们开始有点像，多即兴发挥一点。等等，你即兴发挥了她做了子宫切除术？你即兴发挥是因为那在另一集中有回报吗？不，不，不，不，不。
That was in there, the hysterectomy, but the line that I thought you didn't have a vagina was mine. Oh, because you... Okay. Yeah. That sounds like you. Isabel has been wanting to watch The Office Rain and I haven't let her yet, but now all of her friends have seen it in fifth grade.
那是剧本里的，子宫切除术，但我说“我以为你没有阴道”那句台词是我的。哦，因为你……好吧。是的。那听起来像你。伊莎贝尔一直想看《办公室》，雷恩，但我还没让她看，但现在她五年级的所有朋友都看过了。
So I let her watch this episode with me. In fifth grade, her friends have seen The Office? Her friends, oh my God, they're obsessed. Oh, that's when it starts now. That's when it starts. Fifth grade. Fifth grade. But fifth grade is young.
所以我让她和我一起看这一集。五年级，她的朋友们看过《办公室》？她的朋友们，天哪，他们着迷了。哦，那就是现在开始的时候。那就是开始的时候。五年级。五年级。但五年级太小了。
Fifth grade is young. And so Isabel hasn't seen The Office, and I didn't have her watch it because I didn't think it was age-appropriate and also I just need to be mom, you know? But she's getting more curious now and so she loves the bloopers. So we've watched the bloopers because they were on YouTube. And then I was rewatching this episode and she wanted to watch it. So I let her watch it with me and it's so her introduction to The Office is healthcare. Oh my goodness. And so anal fissures. That's it. That's it. Okay, so that that scene came up and she was like, wait, mom, that's not a real thing. Is it? What is that? And I was like, Oh, God, it is a real thing. And then she's like, but if you ride on the New York, if you ride on
五年级太小了。所以伊莎贝尔没看过《办公室》，我没让她看，因为我觉得不适合她的年龄，而且我只是需要做个妈妈，你知道吗？但她现在越来越好奇了，所以她喜欢花絮。所以我们看了花絮，因为它们在YouTube上。然后我正在重看这一集，她想看。所以我让她和我一起看，所以她对《办公室》的介绍就是“医疗保健”。天哪。还有肛裂。就是这样。就是这样。好吧，所以那一幕出现了，她说，等等，妈妈，那不是真的，对吧？那是什么？我说，哦，天哪，那是真的。然后她说，但如果你坐纽约，如果你坐
the New York subway, they have ads up for anal fissures. There you go. You can read all about them. Well, Isabel turned to me and goes, does Brian have anal fissures? I'm like, no. No. Brian doesn't.
纽约地铁，他们有肛裂的广告。给你。你可以读到所有关于它们的信息。好吧，伊莎贝尔转向我说，布莱恩有肛裂吗？我说，没有。没有。布莱恩没有。
Brian does not. Kevin does. Kevin does. And anyway, it was just sort of funny to watch the episode with her. Well, this is a little bit off the topic of healthcare, but a little on the topic of just how we're friends in real life.
布莱恩没有。凯文有。凯文有。总之，和她一起看这一集很有趣。好吧，这有点偏离了医疗保健的话题，但有点关于我们在现实生活中是如何成为朋友的。
People ask that all the time. We're friends in real life, right, Rain? Rain? Yes, yes, yes we are, Jenna. Okay, we've gone to lunch. We text and we talk to one another. Do you need affirming? Can I get this in writing?
人们总是问那个。我们在现实生活中是朋友，对吧，雷恩？雷恩？是的，是的，是的，我们是，珍娜。好吧，我们一起吃过午饭。我们发短信，我们互相交谈。你需要确认吗？我能书面记录下来吗？
Do you need affirming? No, okay. No, that we're all friends in real life and that we shared so much of our lives doing the show for so long. I remember that your wife, Holliday, was pregnant with your son when we were shooting the pilot. Yes. And then I remember how he was born during an episode, but Rain, I couldn't remember which episode it was. We were shooting. So Walter was born during the Hot Girl, first girl episode.
你需要确认吗？不，好吧。不，我们在现实生活中都是朋友，我们在拍这部剧时分享了我们生命中这么多时间。我记得你妻子霍莉在拍试播集时怀着你的儿子。是的。然后我记得他是怎么在一集中出生的，但雷恩，我不记得是哪一集了。我们当时在拍。所以沃尔特是在“辣妹”那一集，第一集女孩那一集出生的。
Oh, right. So they shot me out the first two days. They just were like, oh, we'll just shoot all Rain's scenes on Monday and Tuesday, and then sure enough, late Tuesday night, Walter was born, and it was a horrific a really difficult birth. And we were in the hospital emergency room and all that kind of stuff.
哦，对。所以他们在前两天就把我的戏份拍完了。他们只是说，哦，我们就在周一和周二拍完雷恩所有的戏份，然后果然，周二深夜，沃尔特出生了，那是一次可怕的、非常困难的分娩。我们在医院急诊室，诸如此类的事情。
You can read about that in my book, The Bassoon King. Yes, yes. I did read about it in your book. Available now. No, I wasn't talking to you two. I was talking to all the listeners out there. Listeners, if you want the full story,
你可以在我的书《巴松管之王》里读到那个。是的，是的。我确实在你的书里读到了。现在有售。不，我不是在跟你们俩说话。我是在跟所有的听众说话。听众们，如果你想要完整的故事，
you can read about it in the Bassoon King. The Bassoon King. Yes. It's a very good book. So that was kind of crazy. And then I had a couple days off and I don't know. We shot out of order. Yeah.
你可以在《巴松管之王》里读到。巴松管之王。是的。那是一本很好的书。所以那有点疯狂。然后我休息了几天，我不知道。我们拍得乱七八糟的。是的。
So because Hot Girl is the last episode that airs for season one, but it was, we shot it in the middle. Healthcare was actually the last episode that we shot. And you had a little tiny Walter while you were shooting this episode. Yeah. And I remember you had to come back to work Monday. You only had what?
所以因为“辣妹”是第一季播出的最后一集，但它是，我们在中间拍的。医疗保健实际上是我们拍的最后一集。你拍这一集时，沃尔特还很小。是的。我记得你周一必须回来工作。你只有什么？
You were so tired. Five days off after he was born. We spent the whole weekend in the hospital. My wife was in the hospital for like four or five days. So we went home from the hospital, maybe Sunday night or even that Monday morning. And I came to work on Monday. You came to work. Oh my God.
你太累了。他出生后休息了五天。我们整个周末都在医院。我妻子在医院待了四五天。所以我们从医院回家，可能是周日晚上，甚至周一早上。我周一就来工作了。你来工作了。天哪。
And I remember being worried. I remember just thinking, just being concerned for- I hope that you guys are okay. Yeah. Just emotionally what that meant. Yeah. Everything worked out great. She's great.
我记得我很担心。我记得我只是在想，只是关心——我希望你们没事。是的。从情感上讲这意味着什么。是的。一切都很顺利。她很好。
Walter's great. All aces. It's all aces. I remember the first time I met your wife was when we were filming the pilot and I remember how you introduced me to her. I'll never forget it. You said, this is my wife, carrier of my seed.
沃尔特很好。一切都好。一切都好。我记得我第一次见到你妻子是在我们拍试播集的时候，我记得你是怎么把我介绍给她的。我永远不会忘记。你说，这是我妻子，我种子的携带者。
That's such a Dwight thing to say. Yeah. And we were like, oh, thanks for being here. And she was like, yeah, hi, I'm Holly. Oh, Rayne. The line blurs. Yeah, it definitely blurs between me and Dwight. And I think the line blurs between all of us and our characters in some regard.
那真是太德怀特了。是的。我们当时说，哦，谢谢你来这里。她说，是的，嗨，我是霍莉。哦，雷恩。界限模糊了。是的，我和德怀特之间的界限绝对模糊了。我认为我们所有人与我们的角色之间的界限在某种程度上都模糊了。
For sure. Rayne, thank you so much for talking with us on our podcast. Hey, this was great. I love the healthcare episode. And if you'll invite me back I'll come into the studio and we can sit down and high fives and ice tea. Yes, let's do that. And you guys we have to all check out Rain's new podcast Metaphysical Milkshake. Yep. And Rain that is on what where do we find that? It's on Luminary. Luminary. Download the Luminary app and it'll be right on that Luminary app.
当然。雷恩，非常感谢你和我们在播客上聊天。嘿，这太棒了。我喜欢医疗保健那一集。如果你再邀请我，我会去演播室，我们可以坐下来击掌喝冰茶。是的，我们这样做吧。你们大家，我们都必须去看看雷恩的新播客《形而上学的奶昔》。是的，雷恩，那个在哪里？在哪里可以找到？在Luminary上。Luminary。下载Luminary应用程序，它就在那个应用程序上。
Well, I can't wait to listen. Rain, I love you so much. Thank you. We love you. I love you guys and miss you. I'm so happy you're doing this podcast and the fans are just going to love it. I hope so. All right, Rain.
好吧，我迫不及待想听了。雷恩，我太爱你了。谢谢。我们爱你。我也爱你们，想念你们。我很高兴你们在做这个播客，粉丝们一定会喜欢的。我希望如此。好吧，雷恩。
Okay, come back. Okay, we love you. Bye. Okay. Bye. See you soon. Bye. Thanks, guys. Why is it every time we talk to someone from the show, I wanna start to cry?
好的，再来。好的，我们爱你。再见。好的。再见。很快见。再见。谢谢，伙计们。为什么每次我们和剧组的人聊天，我都想哭？
Like I'm like tearing up a little. I don't know. I think it's just that those relationships are so fundamental to us. Yes. They are like family. And it doesn't, it's a crew member, it's a cast member. It doesn't matter.
就像我有点泪流满面。我不知道。我想这只是因为那些关系对我们来说太基础了。是的。他们就像家人一样。而且，无论是剧组成员还是演员，都没关系。
It's just such a special chapter in our lives. And just hearing Rain's voice and him laughing at you and I being chatty, it just brought me straight back. Rain, thank you so much for coming on. That just made my day. ["The Daily Show"] Angela, I want to talk about something
这只是我们生命中如此特别的一章。听到雷恩的声音，他嘲笑你和我聊天，这直接把我带回去了。雷恩，非常感谢你来。这让我的这一天变得很美好。["每日秀"] 安吉拉，我想谈谈
that was one of our other most popular questions. And it came from a fan, and it's something I was one of our other most popular questions. And it came from a fan and it's something I was wondering about as well. When I watched this episode, it has to do with the accounting department. So this is for you. Paige O. Murphy asked, I love how you get to see the start of the dynamic between the accounting department and healthcare. And this is when you're leaving the conference room and you say, you let him walk all over you. And-
这是我们另一个最受欢迎的问题。它来自一位粉丝，这也是我好奇的事情。当我观看这一集时，它与会计部门有关。所以这是给你的。佩奇·O·墨菲问，我喜欢你们如何看到会计部门和医疗保健之间的动态开始。这是你离开会议室时说的，你说，你让他对你颐指气使。而且——
I'm like, did you talk to him? Did you talk to him? What was that? I'm like, it's pathetic. You let him walk all over you. And then Kevin's like, what are you guys talking about? And I'm like, nothing, Kevin. Okay, so her question is,
我说，你跟他说话了吗？你跟他说话了吗？那是什么？我说，太可悲了。你让他对你颐指气使。然后凯文说，你们在说什么？我说，没什么，凯文。好吧，所以她的问题是，
how much of that was you guys improvising and how much was written? This is to me, like the quintessential accounting department dynamic. Yes, this is on my note card because to me this really defined our corner, this moment. Yeah, so let's watch it and then I wanna hear, I wanna hear the real story. Oh my God.
有多少是你们即兴发挥的，有多少是写好的？这对我来说，就像典型的会计部门动态。是的，这在我的笔记卡上，因为对我来说，这一刻真正定义了我们的角落。是的，让我们看看它，然后我想听听，我想听听真实的故事。天哪。
This is not good. That's ridiculous. Did you talk to him? What was that? You let him walk all over you. It's just pathetic. What are you guys talking about? Nothing, Kevin. There it is. There it is.
这不好。那太荒谬了。你跟他说话了吗？那是什么？你让他对你颐指气使。这太可悲了。你们在说什么？没什么，凯文。就是这样。就是这样。
Okay, so. So we improvised that. And here's the thing that I learned really quickly on this show. And I learned it from our B camera operator, Matt Zone. Okay. Matt was like, Ang, if you guys have bits, make them quick and they have a chance of getting in the show. And so we had this little guy, and he was like, I'm going to do this.
好吧，所以。所以我们即兴发挥了。我在这个节目中学到的一件事很快。我是从我们的B摄像机操作员马特·佐恩那里学到的。好吧。马特说，安吉，如果你们有小段子，让它们简短，它们就有机会进入节目。所以我们有这个小家伙，他说，我要做这个。
And I was like, I'm going to do this. And he was like, I'm going to do this. And I was like, I'm going to do this. And he was like, I'm going to do this. And I was like, I'm going to do this. And he was like, I'm going to do this. And I was like, I'm going to do this. And he was like, I'm going to do this. And I was like, I'm going to do this. And he was like, I'm going to do this.. Matt was like, Ang, if you guys have bits, make them quick and they have a chance of getting in the show.
我说，我要做这个。马特说，安吉，如果你们有小段子，让它们简短，它们就有机会进入节目。
And so we had this moment where we were all walking back to our desks and Oscar and I kind of improvised this moment where I'm like, did you talk to him? And he's like, what was that? And then we kind of just had this chit chat on the way and our B camera operator got it. And he was like, guys, if you tighten that up, it's gonna make it, it'll make it in, I think,
所以我们有这个时刻，我们都在走回我们的办公桌，奥斯卡和我即兴发挥了这个时刻，我说，你跟他说话了吗？他说，那是什么？然后我们在路上聊了聊，我们的B摄像机操作员拍到了。他说，伙计们，如果你们把它收紧一点，它会成功的，我想，
if you tighten it up. So we did, we had this back and forth. And then of course, like I had no idea that Brian was already walking up behind us. And so he was like, what are you talking about? So I was just like, nothing, Kevin. And it just sort of crystallized that, you know, like Oscar and I have this like weird sort of like office, like dysfunctional marriage in a way, you know, like Oscar and I have this like weird sort of like office,
如果你把它收紧一点。所以我们做了，我们有了这个来回。然后当然，我不知道布莱恩已经走在我们身后了。所以他说，你们在说什么？所以我只是说，没什么，凯文。它只是结晶了，你知道，奥斯卡和我有一种奇怪的，像办公室里那种功能失调的婚姻，你知道吗？
like dysfunctional marriage in a way, you know? And that Kevin is like our child that we're like, just stay out of it, leave him out of it. And it was just so fun that it made it in for us. That was really fun. How did that dynamic come together? Because I know you guys would have to get stuck in the background, we've established that, but for real, you did. And I know you guys would have to get stuck in the background. We've established that, but for real, you did.
而且凯文就像我们的孩子，我们就像，别管它，别让他参与。这太有趣了，它成功进入了节目。那真的很有趣。那种动态是怎么结合在一起的？因为我知道你们必须被困在背景里，我们已经确定了，但说真的，你们确实做到了。
And I know you guys are all comedic improv performers. Well, Oscar and I had done a show together. We met well before the office. I've talked about this before. We had done a sketch show together called Hot Towel, and we'd known each other a long time. We had done the Groundlings together, and I think we just naturally fell into step with one another.
而且我知道你们都是喜剧即兴表演者。好吧，奥斯卡和我一起做过一个节目。我们在《办公室》之前就认识了。我之前谈过这个。我们一起做过一个叫《热毛巾》的素描节目，我们认识很久了。我们一起做过《Groundlings》，我想我们自然而然地步调一致了。
I knew my character was always annoyed. That was like a base. That was your default. My baseline is I was always annoyed. And then just the way that Brian did Kevin, he seemed a little bit like the idiot. Yeah, he was, yeah. So pretty much if I had anyone I could go to
我知道我的角色总是很烦。那是基础。那是你的默认设置。我的基线是我总是很烦。然后布莱恩演凯文的方式，他看起来有点像个白痴。是的，他是，是的。所以基本上如果我有任何人可以去找
about something, it was Oscar. And I was always annoyed and I was always going to him and he never had the answers I wanted. And then I just didn't want to even talk to Kevin. So that just sort of like came about naturally, I think. And Oscar and I just picked up on all those cues. Well, I love that Greg and the directors gave our camera operators the license to pick up moments
关于某事，那就是奥斯卡。我总是很烦，我总是去找他，他从来没有我想要的答案。然后我甚至不想和凯文说话。所以这自然而然地发生了，我想。奥斯卡和我只是捕捉到了所有那些暗示。好吧，我喜欢格雷格和导演们给我们的摄像机操作员许可去捕捉那些
that they hadn't even been directed. To pick up. Yeah, like they would keep one eye open on everything that was happening in the background. And especially Matt, his job was to catch reactions and to catch these little moments that were happening off of the main action. And Matt went on to direct episodes in later seasons.
他们甚至没有被指导去捕捉的时刻。是的，就像他们会睁一只眼闭一只眼看着背景中发生的一切。尤其是马特，他的工作是捕捉反应和捕捉发生在主要动作之外的这些小时刻。马特后来在以后的几季里执导了剧集。
Yes, he did. And our director of this episode, Ken Whittingham, was so great about letting us have that creative opportunity. So when he saw us do that as we walked away, he was like, yeah, yeah, keep doing that. And so he encouraged us and then, you know, we used to joke that we would have just kept going and going. And so I'd be like, I'd have to say,
是的，他做到了。我们这一集的导演肯·惠廷汉姆非常棒，让我们有了那个创造性的机会。所以当他看到我们走开时这样做，他说，是的，是的，继续这样做。所以他鼓励我们，然后，你知道，我们过去常开玩笑说我们会一直继续下去。所以我不得不说，
I would say all the time to Brian and Oscar, it's not our show, guys. It's it's not, it's not our show guys. It's not our show. It's not our show. And then we had this whole like running bit that we did for years that there was an actual spinoff called Los Acantadores, Oscar, Angela, y que bien. And it lived on Telemundo.
我一直对布莱恩和奥斯卡说，这不是我们的节目，伙计们。这不是我们的节目。这不是我们的节目。然后我们有一个运行了多年的小段子，有一个实际的衍生剧叫《Los Acantadores》，奥斯卡，安吉拉，y que bien。它在Telemundo上播出。
That was our spinoff. Angela, that is actually a really good idea for a spinoff. Just, just- The accountants. The accountants. And Creed. And Creed. The accountants and Creed. The accountants. Well, I just think Creed has to work in every office. Yes, somehow, right? Yes. Like, he's always there. I actually would like Creed to be in every project.
那是我们的衍生剧。安吉拉，这实际上是一个很好的衍生剧主意。只是，只是——会计师们。会计师们。还有克里德。还有克里德。会计师们和克里德。会计师们。好吧，我只是觉得克里德必须在每个办公室工作。是的，以某种方式，对吧？是的。就像，他总是在那里。我实际上希望克里德出现在每个项目中。
I need a phone number. Who's? I need to call someone at NBC. Who are you calling? I don't know. I think this is gold. I actually would like Creed to just show up in every project I have for the rest of my life. Also, he texted me this morning and he really wants to come on the show. So I said- Well, he's coming on the show. Yeah, that's happening. I know exactly what episode too.
我需要一个电话号码。谁的？我需要给NBC的某个人打电话。你在给谁打电话？我不知道。我觉得这是金子。我实际上希望克里德出现在我余生中的每个项目中。另外，他今天早上给我发短信，他真的很想上节目。所以我说——好吧，他要上节目了。是的，那正在发生。我也确切地知道是哪一集。
Oh, you've got it all figured out. Yeah, he needs to come on for the Halloween episode, which is the first episode that he speaks. No, Jenna, that is not the first episode that he speaks in. What? Yeah. Lady, look at my note card. first episode that he speaks in. What? Yeah. Lady, look at my note card.
哦，你都想好了。是的，他需要参加万圣节那一集，那是他说话的第一集。不，珍娜，那不是他说话的第一集。什么？是的。女士，看我的笔记卡。
He has a few lines in this episode of healthcare. What? Creed does not speak in healthcare. Yes, he does. No, he does not. Lady, you have to listen. Okay, so you know the scene when Michael calls the Lackawanna coal mine?
他在“医疗保健”这一集里有几句台词。什么？克里德在“医疗保健”里没说话。是的，他说了。不，他没有。女士，你必须听。好吧，你知道迈克尔给拉卡瓦纳煤矿打电话的那一幕吗？
Yes. For you know, he's calling because he's like, hey, is there some kind of ride there? And there's a voice that's like, well, you know, it's an industrial elevator goes 300 feet into the ground really slowly. And Michael's like, what is there laser tag down there? And he's like, nope.
是的。你知道，他打电话是因为他说，嘿，那里有什么车吗？有一个声音说，嗯，你知道，这是一个工业电梯，慢慢地进入地下300英尺。迈克尔说，那里有激光枪战吗？他说，没有。
Remember that guy? Yeah. It's Creed. What? Yes. The voice of the coal miner guy is Creed? Yeah! No way!
记得那个人吗？是的。是克里德。什么？是的。煤矿工人的声音是克里德？是的！不会吧！
Well, between the two of us, I'm sure someone out there caught this, but I was watching this episode with my daughter and she was like, mommy, that voice sounds familiar. And I was like, it does. The voice of the man that works at the coal mine sounded familiar to us. And I was like, oh my gosh, it's Creed. It's Creed. And I texted Creed and he said, yeah, I was so excited. He said that Ken Quapus, who was a friend of his, who was our director, he said, you know, Creed, why don't you read this? And Creed did and they were really happy with it. And he really felt like that helped him sort of down the line for Halloween because they already thought he was funny.
好吧，我们俩之间，我相信外面有人捕捉到了这一点，但我正在和我的女儿看这一集，她说，妈妈，那个声音听起来很熟悉。我说，确实。那个在煤矿工作的人的声音对我们来说听起来很熟悉。我说，天哪，是克里德。是克里德。我给克里德发了短信，他说，是的，我太兴奋了。他说肯·夸普斯，他的一个朋友，我们的导演，他说，你知道，克里德，你为什么不读这个？克里德读了，他们对此非常满意。他真的觉得这对他万圣节的演出有帮助，因为他们已经认为他很有趣了。
And he is so funny. He's so funny and his timing is perfect. Perfect. Yes. But I want you to know, I said, Creed, oh my gosh. So that was your first speaking part on the office was as that coal miner guy. Yeah.
他确实很有趣。他太有趣了，他的时机把握得完美无缺。完美。是的。但我希望你知道，我说，克里德，天哪。所以那是你在《办公室》里的第一个说话角色，作为那个煤矿工人。是的。
And he goes, no. What? I know. This is what? I know. This is episode three. I know, I know you don't know this and I'm bouncing in my This is episode three. I know. I know.
他说，不。什么？我知道。这是什么？我知道。这是第三集。我知道，我知道你不知道这个，我正在我的椅子上跳，因为你不知道这个。
You don't know this. And I'm bouncing in my chair because you don't know this. Okay. The actual first time that Creed ever spoke was in Diversity Day. What? Yes. So at the time they needed some banter and our first AD did not realize that Creed wasn't a series regular and didn't have a contract.
你不知道这个。我正在我的椅子上跳，因为你不知道这个。好吧。克里德第一次说话实际上是在“多元化日”。什么？是的。当时他们需要一些玩笑，我们的第一助理导演没有意识到克里德不是系列常规演员，没有合同。
That he was just a background player. Just a background player. And you're literally like that the contract for background player is you are not allowed to speak. If you speak, there's a big bump in pay. And they have to pay you. Yeah. Creed said the AD said to him, can you fill in some banter with Phyllis?
他只是一个背景演员。只是一个背景演员。你简直就像背景演员的合同是你不能说话。如果你说话，薪水会有很大的提升。他们必须付钱给你。是的。克里德说助理导演对他说，你能和菲利斯填补一些玩笑吗？
And Creed was like, you know me, Ange, I'm not shy. So he has this banter with Phyllis and it made it in the episode. And then they realized they wanted to use it, but Creed wasn't officially under contract. So then they paid him and that is actually his first line. Well, my mind is blown. Your mind is blown because Creed actually had an improv line in diversity day that made it in the show. And that is the first time he spoke.
克里德说，你了解我，安吉，我不害羞。所以他和菲利斯开了玩笑，它进入了剧集。然后他们意识到他们想用它，但克里德没有正式签约。所以他们付了钱给他，那实际上是他的第一句台词。好吧，我的大脑被震撼了。你的大脑被震撼了，因为克里德在“多元化日”里确实有一句即兴台词进入了节目。那是他第一次说话。
The second time he spoke was the elevator shaft operator guy on the phone with Michael. And then Halloween, as we will get to, is his big, big moment. Yes. Oh, that is some good stuff. That was a good note card, lady. Very good note card. OK, Angela, well, I have trivia.
他第二次说话是电话里和迈克尔通话的电梯井操作员。然后万圣节，正如我们将要谈到的，是他巨大的时刻。是的。哦，那是一些好东西。那是一张很好的笔记卡，女士。非常好的笔记卡。好的，安吉拉，我有琐事。
I have trivia. Why are you looking at me like that? I don't know. I have trivia. I'm feeling very smug with looking at me like that? I don't know. I have trivia. I'm feeling very smug with my Cree trivia. Well, it was really good. All right, here's mine. You know the scene when Michael goes to the travel agent
我有琐事。你为什么那样看着我？我不知道。我有琐事。我感觉非常自鸣得意，看着我那样？我不知道。我有琐事。我感觉非常自鸣得意，带着我的克里德琐事。好吧，那真的很好。好吧，这是我的。你知道迈克尔去旅行社的那一幕
where he wants to try to get us the all expense paid trip to Atlantic City, where he says the thing about like, isn't there like bus that takes you there and then you get all your meals comped? Everything's free. Everything's free and the travel agent is like, yeah, I don't really know anything about that. You might wanna just contact the casino directly.
他想尝试为我们争取到大西洋城的全额付费旅行，他说关于，难道没有那种带你去那里的巴士，然后你所有的餐费都报销了吗？一切都是免费的。一切都是免费的，旅行社说，是的，我真的不知道关于那个的任何事情。你可能想直接联系赌场。
Do you know who played the travel agent? Is it his friend from college, Charlie Hartsock? Damn it, Angela. I remember that. I remember Steve was really excited because his friend from, you know, like his good friend was gonna be on set that day. But you weren't there that day.
你知道是谁演的旅行社吗？是他大学的朋友查理·哈特索克吗？该死，安吉拉。我记得那个。我记得史蒂夫非常兴奋，因为他的朋友，你知道，他的好朋友那天要来片场。但你那天不在那里。
I wasn't Jenna, but Steve is my friend and he shared with me. Oh man. Yeah. Uh-huh. All right, well, what else have you got? You got more note cards over there. You know what, Jenna, when I was watching this,
我不在，珍娜，但史蒂夫是我的朋友，他和我分享了。哦，伙计。是的。嗯哼。好吧，你还有什么？你那边还有更多的笔记卡。你知道吗，珍娜，当我观看这一集时，
I was like, oh my gosh, this really, this episode in particular, I felt like we really saw that, that peep shot. And I know we're going to talk about it. The peep shot, the spy shot, Angela? I call it the peep shot. Well, hey, you- Please don't call it that to anyone else. It's called the spy shot.
我在想，天哪，这一集特别，我觉得我们真的看到了那个，那个窥视镜头。我知道我们要谈论它。窥视镜头，间谍镜头，安吉拉？我叫它窥视镜头。好吧，嘿，你——请不要那样称呼它给别人。它叫间谍镜头。
Well, you, you just called it- We're spying. We're not peeping. Excuse me. You called the background actors lurkers. So we're lurking and we're peeping. Okay. But it's just that shot.
好吧，你，你刚才叫它——我们在间谍。我们不是在窥视。对不起。你叫背景演员潜伏者。所以我们在潜伏，我们在窥视。好吧。但这只是那个镜头
Wow. Well, you just called the... We're spying. We're not peeping. Excuse me. You called the background actors lurkers. So we're lurking and we're peeping. Okay. But it's just that shot where you go through the blinds, right? And we saw that a lot in this episode because Michael is hiding. He is hiding in his office. And one of my favorite ones when you're being sassy, the PAM sass. Oh my gosh.
哇。好吧，你刚才叫……我们在间谍。我们不是在窥视。对不起。你叫背景演员潜伏者。所以我们在潜伏，我们在窥视。好吧。但这只是那个镜头，你穿过百叶窗，对吧？我们在这一集里看到了很多，因为迈克尔在躲藏。他躲在他的办公室里。我最喜欢的一个是当你变得厚颜无耻时，帕姆的厚颜无耻。天哪。
This is a peep and a sass? It's a peep and a PAM sass. So we're looking through the blinds and Michael is just playing with his truck. He's rolling the truck back and forth. And he's claiming that there's many calls coming in. Yeah, busy, busy, busy, busy. And Pam goes, still no one calling. Still no one calling.
这是一个窥视和一个厚颜无耻？这是一个窥视和一个帕姆的厚颜无耻。所以我们透过百叶窗看，迈克尔只是在玩他的卡车。他来回滚动卡车。他声称有很多电话打进来。是的，忙，忙，忙，忙。帕姆说，还是没人打电话。还是没人打电话。
It's matter of fact. You find matter of factness to be sass. No, I think there's a little bit of sass on it. But yeah, so I thought I love that you got to see how we spy on people through the camera, that we get to see these moments they don't know that we're seeing. Yeah. And you'll see it over and over. But when I watched the BBC version of the show,
这是事实。你发现事实是厚颜无耻。不，我觉得上面有一点厚颜无耻。但是的，所以我认为我喜欢你看到我们如何通过摄像机监视人们，我们能看到他们不知道我们正在看到的这些时刻。是的。你会一遍又一遍地看到它。但当我观看该节目的BBC版本时，
and then when I watched our version, those were the only shows doing that at this time. We were really trying to employ what you would do on an actual documentary, where you want to, like, catch people when they're not aware they're being filmed. And we behave differently when we are being... know we're being filmed or not. And so that was, we would use the spy shot
然后当我观看我们的版本时，那些是当时唯一在做那个的节目。我们真的试图采用你在实际纪录片中会做的事情，你想，就像，在人们不知道他们被拍摄时捕捉他们。当我们被……知道我们被拍摄或不被拍摄时，我们的行为是不同的。所以那是，我们会使用间谍镜头
when we needed to catch people. Or the peep shot. Okay. Or the peep shot, as Angela's calling it. Moving on. All right, next card. Two observations about John in this episode. The first one has to do with his hair. John has a full on bowl haircut in this.
当我们需要抓住人们的时候。或者“窥视镜头”。好吧。或者像安吉拉所说的“窥视镜头”。继续。好的，下一张卡片。关于约翰在这一集里的两个观察。第一个与他的头发有关。约翰在这集里留了一个十足的碗盖头。
What? Yes, Sam, can you pull up a picture of John in this to show Jenna? I grew up in a small town and some of these farm boys, they would just put a bowl on their head and cut their hair around it. What was that about? I don't know.
什么？是的，山姆，你能调出一张约翰在这集里的照片给珍娜看吗？我在一个小镇长大，有些农场男孩，他们就会在头上扣个碗，然后沿着碗边剪头发。那是怎么回事？我不知道。
Look at that! Oh, oh, at 14 minutes and 19 seconds. That's full bowl. Full bowl, okay. And then the other thing I noticed about John is that John says de-white. He does say de-white. He says de-white.
看那个！哦，哦，在14分19秒的时候。那是十足的碗盖头。十足的碗盖头，好吧。然后我注意到的关于约翰的另一件事是，约翰说“de-white”。他确实说了“de-white”。他说“de-white”。
I say Dwight. I say Dwight. He said, well, he doesn't say de-white, he says de-. I say Dwight. I say Dwight. He said, well, he doesn't say D white. He says D white. D white. Okay. D white. John says D white. D white.
我说“Dwight”。我说“Dwight”。他说，嗯，他不说“D white”，他说“D white”。“D white”。好吧。“D white”。约翰说“D white”。“D white”。
D white. D white. Oh my God. John says D white. And I say Dwight. I say Dwight. Dwight. I absolutely love it now cause it just makes me miss John.
“D white”。“D white”。天哪。约翰说“D white”。而我说“Dwight”。我说“Dwight”。“Dwight”。我现在绝对喜欢它，因为它让我怀念约翰。
And every time I hear him say D now because it just makes me miss John. And every time I hear him say Dwight, it just makes me smile. So there are my two John observations. I have an observation about Jim in this episode, which is, and actually, if Fan pointed this out as well, I had noticed it, but I will give some props to the other person who noticed it, except I don't have their to the other person who noticed it, except I don't have their name written down. I'm sorry.
每次听到他说“D”时，因为它让我怀念约翰。每次听到他说“Dwight”时，它总是让我微笑。所以这就是我关于约翰的两个观察。我在这集里对吉姆也有一个观察，实际上，有粉丝也指出了这一点，我注意到了，但我会给那个也注意到的人一些赞赏，除了我没有记下他们的名字。我很抱歉。
Person out there, you know who you are. Which is that all of this could have been avoided if Jim had just taken 15 minutes and picked a plan. No, I know. The way he was asked in the beginning of the episode. Yes. I mean, he ends up having this fun, playful day with Pam, but if we're going to get real here, it cost him
那位粉丝，你知道你是谁。那就是如果吉姆花15分钟选定一个计划，这一切本可以避免。不，我知道。他在这一集开头被问到的方式。是的。我的意思是，他最终和帕姆度过了这个有趣、愉快的日子，但如果我们现实一点，这让他付出了代价
and everyone else in the office decent healthcare. On the other hand, in his defense, I will say, the task was to slash the healthcare. So I'm not sure he could have done much better than Dwight, but maybe he could have. Does that make him kind of not as charming? I don't know. This, I think what happens, I think what happens in this show is that Michael passes the buck to Jim and Jim passes it to Dwight and it happens over and over. It does. It does. And Jim is just like, listen, I don't get paid enough to do this. Yeah. Well, and I think the argument really can be made that Jim knew it was inevitable. Like what we ended up with is what we were going to end up with.
以及办公室里的其他人付出了体面的医疗保险。另一方面，为他辩护，我会说，任务是削减医疗保险。所以我不太确定他是否能比德怀特做得更好，但也许他可以。这让他显得不那么迷人了吗？我不知道。我想在这部剧中发生的事情是，迈克尔把责任推给吉姆，吉姆又把它推给德怀特，这种情况反复发生。确实如此。确实如此。而吉姆只是觉得，听着，我拿的钱不够做这个。是的。嗯，我认为确实可以提出这样的论点，即吉姆知道这是不可避免的。就像我们最终得到的结果就是我们注定要得到的结果一样。
Although the other argument can be made that Dwight made it worse than it needed to be. OK, I have another note card. OK. OK, here it is. So one of the things I love about our props department is just all the little details in the back. And a great example of this is all of the motivational posters
尽管也可以提出另一种论点，即德怀特让情况变得比原本需要的更糟。好的，我还有一张笔记卡。好的。好的，在这里。所以，我喜欢我们道具部门的一点就是背景里的所有小细节。这方面的一个很好的例子就是你在邓德·米夫林周围看到的那些励志海报
that you see around Dunder Mifflin. There's so many. They're brilliant. They're brilliant. I like to think that like Michael Scott really thinks they're going to get everyone to like feel affirmed in their day. So you know, there's one behind you in reception that just says teamwork.
你看到的那些。它们太棒了。它们太棒了。我喜欢认为迈克尔·斯科特真的认为它们会让每个人在一天中感到被肯定。所以你知道，接待处你身后就有一张写着“团队合作”。
Yep. And it's a bunch of people they've jumped out of a plane and they're all locking arms. That teamwork. Teamwork. These are all over the office though. At 15 minutes, 50 seconds around there, it flashes to the clock on the wall. And under the clock, you just see it says, self-affirmations, self-esteem.
是的。那是一群人从飞机上跳下来，他们都挽着手臂。那是团队合作。团队合作。不过这些海报贴满了办公室。在15分50秒左右，镜头闪到了墙上的时钟。在时钟下面，你看到写着“自我肯定，自尊”。
And then you can't see what else it says, but I'm like, what is under the clock? What are all these self-affirmations? The detail work in our set design was incredible. And that was Michael Gallenberg. He was our set designer. He was so amazing. And so many details.
然后你看不见它还写了什么，但我当时想，时钟下面是什么？所有这些自我肯定是什么？我们布景设计中的细节工作令人难以置信。那是迈克尔·加伦伯格。他是我们的布景设计师。他太棒了。而且有太多的细节。
And then the props department would, any time there was some sheet of paper that we had to look at as a prop, it was a fully formed idea. If there was a memo, they wrote out a whole real fake memo. And they were funny. On Dunder Mifflin, stationary. There's always funny little jokes hidden in them. And also all around the office,
然后道具部门会，任何时候有我们需要作为道具看的纸张，它都是一个完整的想法。如果有一份备忘录，他们会写出一份完整的真实假备忘录。而且它们很有趣。在邓德·米夫林的信纸上。总是隐藏着有趣的小笑话。而且在办公室周围也是，
if you're in the break room, the menus, the magnets on the fridge, they're all from Scranton. Yeah. They reached out to local businesses in Scranton and they all sent their items and they're all throughout our office. Also, of course, Froggy 95.5, local Scranton radio. That's what should be your playlist.
如果你在休息室，菜单、冰箱上的磁铁，它们都来自斯克兰顿。是的。他们联系了斯克兰顿当地的企业，他们都寄来了他们的物品，它们遍布我们的办公室。当然，还有Froggy 95.5，斯克兰顿当地的广播电台。那应该是你的播放列表。
You should have just listened to some Froggy. I really should have. All right. This episode ends with Michael coming out of his office. He's successfully hidden in his office until 5 PM, after 5 PM. And the entire office is waiting to confront him, both about the horrible healthcare plan that Dwight picked, and to finally find out, please, what is the surprise. Because he's come in attempting to surprise us with ice cream sandwiches.
你本应该只听听Froggy的。我真的应该听的。好的。这一集以迈克尔走出办公室结束。他成功地躲在办公室里直到下午5点，下午5点之后。整个办公室都在等着质问他，关于德怀特挑选的糟糕的医疗计划，以及最终找出，拜托，惊喜到底是什么。因为他进来时试图用冰淇淋三明治给我们惊喜。
Oh, he about hit me in the head with an ice cream sandwich. I mean, Steve actually, like, the look on his face after that take, he was like, Angela, how close did that come? I was like, Steve, you pretty much almost hit me in the head with it. And he also announced so proudly, Operation Surprise. Yes. And so we're like, okay, what is it? What is it? And it's all he could come up with in his whole day was ice cream sandwiches. So now it's the end. And then he says that's not the surprise. It's surprising,
哦，他差点用冰淇淋三明治砸到我的头。我的意思是，史蒂夫实际上，在那次拍摄后他脸上的表情，他说，安吉拉，那有多近？我说，史蒂夫，你差点就用它砸到我的头了。他还自豪地宣布了“惊喜行动”。是的。所以我们就像，好吧，那是什么？那是什么？而他整天能想出来的就是冰淇淋三明治。所以现在是结尾了。然后他说那不是惊喜。它是令人惊讶的，
but it is not the surprise. So at the end of the episode you confront him. I do. I love it. I loved being the person that confronted him because Steve is so funny and he turned to me and he's like, yes, Angela. Thank you for reminding me. So you ask him point blank, what is the surprise, Michael? And then he says, the surprise is. And then he short circuits. He just stops talking. He just stops talking and it just starts to have like upper lip sweat. And we all are just looking at him.
但它不是那个惊喜。所以在这一集结束时，你质问他。我质问了。我喜欢它。我喜欢成为质问他的人，因为史蒂夫太搞笑了，他转向我说，是的，安吉拉。谢谢你提醒我。所以你直截了当地问他，惊喜是什么，迈克尔？然后他说，惊喜是。然后他短路了。他就不说话了。他就不说话了，开始出现上唇汗。我们所有人都只是看着他。
It is so awkward. It's so awkward. And I remember when we did it, like timing it out to that moment where we start to like slowly leave each person. Yes. And how long that felt. Yes.
太尴尬了。太尴尬了。我记得当我们拍摄的时候，就像计时到那一刻，我们开始慢慢离开每个人。是的。那种感觉持续了多久。是的。
It felt so long. It really did as we were standing there and they had choreographed the order in which we would leave. And of course we did many takes so we would have to come back and reset. And I remember thinking, are we gonna leave this, this is a giant pause with no dialogue. Is this gonna be able to stand? Cause that was not something you did on television shows. In fact, on television shows, especially comedies,
感觉太长了。当我们站在那里时，确实如此，他们编排了我们离开的顺序。当然我们拍了很多次，所以我们不得不回来重置。我记得当时想，我们要保留这个吗，这是一个没有对话的巨大停顿。这能行得通吗？因为那不是你在电视节目中会做的事情。事实上，在电视节目中，尤其是喜剧中，
it was pretty traditional to have like, set up, set up, joke, set up, set up, joke. And this was like a whole different rhythm. And so, yeah, I remember this. And I remember he just had to stand there. Oh, it was so awkward. And then when you watch it, it's so like cringey, but it's perfect. It's perfect.
传统的做法是像，铺垫，铺垫，笑话，铺垫，铺垫，笑话。而这是一种完全不同的节奏。所以，是的，我记得这个。我记得他只能站在那里。哦，太尴尬了。然后当你观看它时，它非常令人尴尬，但它是完美的。它是完美的。
It's so good. And there's so many times, like when I watch episodes of The Office where I'm like, how does Michael come back from that? Like I say that to myself, like how does he come back the next day and be like, we all knew there was no surprise. We all knew, but man, we made him suffer through that pause. And then best last line ever. After that suffering silence, Rain says, Oh, Jan wants you to call her. So good. So good. That's healthcare, guys. That is healthcare. Thank you so much, Rainn Wilson, for calling in, and it was just so great to hear your
太棒了。有很多次，比如当我观看《办公室》的剧集时，我会想，迈克尔怎么能从那件事中恢复过来？就像我对自己说的那样，他第二天怎么能回来并表现得好像，我们都知道没有惊喜。我们都知道，但天哪，我们让他忍受了那个停顿。然后是有史以来最好的最后一句台词。在那痛苦的沉默之后，雷恩说，哦，简想让你给她回电话。太棒了。太棒了。这就是医疗保险，伙计们。这就是医疗保险。非常感谢雷恩·威尔逊打来电话，听到你的声音真是太好了。
voice. Oh, I'm just going to go listen to the sounds of Scranton. I'll be right back. I'll see you guys next week. See you next week when we do the Alliance. The Alliance. Oh, there's so much good stuff in that lunch. Not to be missed.
哦，我只是要去听听斯克兰顿的声音。我马上回来。下周见。下周见，当我们做“联盟”那一集的时候。“联盟”。哦，那顿午餐里有很多好东西。不容错过。
Not to be missed. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' Second Drink. This episode was initially created in collaboration with Earwulf. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fischer and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins and our audio engineer and associate producer is Daniella Silva. Odyssey's executive producers are Jenna Wise-Berman and Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies is mixed and mastered by Chris Basil. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
不容错过。感谢收听《办公室女士》的第二杯。本集最初是与Earwulf合作创作的。《办公室女士》是Odyssey的一档节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·杰金斯，我们的音频工程师和副制片人是丹妮拉·席尔瓦。Odyssey的执行制片人是珍娜·怀斯-伯曼和莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。《办公室女士》由克里斯·巴兹尔混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《Rubber Tree》。这一集还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。